hello family man hello sir good to see
you brother good to see you too
we were just talking about uh like you
have two kids now you have a real family
you got to get an suv
yeah oh yeah we had something but just
once you get the two car seats in the
back and then you know
with all the [ __ ] for the kids and then
all the [ __ ] your wife has all of a
sudden it's just like oh i now
understand remember this suburban
yeah which was a long like blazer and
you look at that thing like who the [ __ ]
needs all of that unless you're like
homeless and that's where you live but
then you're like oh i get it
again if you have three four kids yeah
you definitely need one you definitely
need one they always bring a bunch of
[ __ ] with them too they want to bring
stuff
so yeah you have to have yeah you have
to have room for a toy or
this or that those tesla ones you were
talking about those are great
the x with the crazy doors yeah the
lambo doors yeah those are dope have you
ever seen them dance
no tiffany haddish had one she's in the
back of the comedy store i heard that
did she uh set it to dance and she puts
music on it
and the wings start going up and the car
starts turning left and right it's
actually pretty badass
it's fun she's one of the most fun
people i've ever hung out with so i i
wish i was i wish i was there for that
she had the covid
she had it she got it over it she she
kicked it
i'm surprised more comics didn't get it
the way we're shaking hands and meeting
people after shows
um yeah i saw my i got
my wife had the kids we had to get
tested so i was i said
yeah big j okay got it he had it
and he's clean it feels weird to be
talking about people that have it yeah
i know a lot of people that caught it
yeah i know about nine
you like naming names like joe mccarthy
over there
they're fine now well i like people
who've had it now because they have the
antibodies they think they can like walk
on fire it's like dude this thing is a
brand new thing i don't know if you want
to be testing
you know i got a buddy of mine uh ended
up getting it and then he was just like
oh they i got tested i got the
antibodies so now i think he feels like
he's bulletproof so
they don't even know if you can catch it
again they don't they really have no
idea
well people are gonna find out yeah
we're gonna find out yeah cause when i
was driving over here i actually got
into a moderate level of traffic
on the highway like i've noticed it's
just
at some point i mean considering people
are just kind of doing what they want to
do
and a lot of people were after two weeks
everyone just
sort of depending on where your ego was
like you know who [ __ ]
tell me this is all [ __ ] something
i'm gonna go outside
those people they just kept it going so
now i just feel like well you can't have
sixty percent of the population go broke
because less than one percent has
something
yeah so i don't know i think we're just
gonna
just go back i think we're just gonna go
back and if you get it you get it and if
you die you die and if you don't you
don't and then
eventually they're gonna get they're
gonna get something that'll slow it down
or stop it or something like that yes it
slows it down your [ __ ] immune system
they don't tell your goddamn thing about
that
they'll tell you how to take care of
your immune system there's no word about
that
put a mask on wash your hands no one's
telling you sleep more
drink water take vitamins there's none
of that yeah i know this one guy brought
up vitamin d in his big podcast and then
you couldn't find it anymore
dude you're like [ __ ] oprah when she
attacked the meat industry
i just saw a clip oh this guy on rogan
of course it didn't even research
who the guy it was like vitamin d a
woman that's
how much i pay attention and then i go i
go to the [ __ ] health food store it's
all gone
and there was something that bootleg
vitamin d it was like vitamin d
plus i'm like what what is that what is
that
i know that that probably gonna make me
catch it so i just take vitamin c and i
try to get eight hours sleep and i i've
been i've been doing a pretty good job
of uh
i'm pretty anti-social like a lot of
comics so i haven't had a problem
keeping away from everybody have you
yeah my word for i quarantined in my
house like my wife said you guys gonna
sit down and have dinner with us i'm
always open
if i'm alone no one can hurt me
that's just leftover childhood [ __ ]
just coming from a family of loners so
do you feel weird not doing stand-up
what has that been like
um i did not miss it at all
and but i think that whenever there's
something like painful in my life i
think that that's what i do as i
i just go i don't care i don't give a
[ __ ] it's all i i really
learned a lot more about myself during
this
quiet time of not running around and
going to airports and kind of sitting
with myself
and being like wow i thought i was way
further down the road working on myself
than i was but i have a lot of [ __ ]
childhood issues left over i gotta i was
like wow
like i really started like all these
puzzle pieces
just started coming in and i was able to
look all the way
back where i was to where where i am now
and how i got here
and these little [ __ ] things that
happened to me
you know good things and bad that just
sort of just knocked me down this road
that i'm on it was just sitting alone
with alone time
yeah well you know my wife was going
through you know the third trimester you
know when
you know when they're just over it and
you're like oh god there's six weeks to
go
i made it happen no he's like oh no
um you know i'd finally
you know get my daughter to bed get her
to bed everything was good made sure all
the doors were locked and then i was
just sort of like
why you know all these years of doing
stand up i'm just up at that hour
right so i was just sort of you know
sitting kind of by myself like i
i don't know i haven't been watching tv
like the news you just brought up three
things
you see he's going on seattle with the
[ __ ] fcc whatever he says
i don't know what i don't even know what
it is what is tifa
antifa they call themselves
anti-fascists
and they're they wear masks and they
carry sticks and helmets and [ __ ] and
they can intimidate people
exactly to stop fascism they use fascism
they like stop fascism yeah and they
blocked off
i think six blocks of seattle and they
declared it a police-free zone
this is occupied by the people of
seattle and you you can't use money in
that police freezer you know joe i'm
going to go out on a limb and say that's
not going to end well
it's not going the only thing that's
going to keep it from ending badly
is that seattle is kind of a [ __ ] up
city they tolerate a lot of homelessness
seattle's got a lot of weird laws like
it's a it's a
um i forget the way it's described i
think it's a mutual combat state that's
what's described
so like if you're in front of a cop say
if uh say if i'm a cop
and you and jamie decide to duke it out
you can just say you want to fight
[ __ ] and you'll go yeah i want
to fight and the cops will let you fight
because it's some wild west mining [ __ ]
from like the [ __ ] sixteen hundreds
settled like men in the books yeah no
lawsuits i like it you can duke it out
in the middle of the street it's very
dangerous though
people getting knocked out on the street
is [ __ ] terrifying because they fall
and they hit their head and they go
unconscious
and there's no refs to stop those last
nine hammer fists i think the cops are
supposed to do that the cops are
supposed to act as a referee too
there's f there's videos of guys getting
into street fights
in seattle and cops just standing around
watching
yeah it's real weird in fact i don't
have a problem if two people are
willing to do it and they they're uh
they know the risks you know if you get
hit you're gonna fall and crack your
head on the back of the
the curb there i mean a lot of them are
drunk though they don't know the risks
there was one of them
this is this kid uh i think his his last
name is fodor
uh i think carlos photo or he was a mma
fighter and he would dress up like a
superhero
what see we can find out do you remember
his name
anyway he actually knew how to fight and
he was dressed like a superhero
so he's kind of baiting people to [ __ ]
with him and he's walking on the street
and
these guys [ __ ] with them and that's
hilarious they decide to go at it and
then
you know he's bouncing around like a
real pro fighter and start slamming leg
kicks in on this guy
you see this guy's face like oh my god
what the [ __ ] have i signed up for
he's just some drunk [ __ ] and some
dude dressed like a superhero i
i don't have any sympathy for those
people call i think he called himself
phoenix jones if i saw a guy
walking around dressed like a superhero
i'd be like that guy's out of his
[ __ ] mind and i would give him a wide
berth
hoping he was on his way to his place of
solitude whatever
[Laughter]
maybe he's on his way home to his ice
house he's on his way to the bat cave
or something but if i was younger uh
yeah i might have
you know if i was standing in a crowd
yeah i probably would have done some
[ __ ]
punk [ __ ] like that couple of whiskeys
in yeah oh yeah get my [ __ ] orange
wig slapped off
yeah probably
[Laughter]
so seattle is on it's run by a warlord
some
one [ __ ] dude apparently according to
my friend was
who's a seal was running this entire
seven block or six block area of seattle
they spray painted all the windows on
this yeah you know
okay talk to me in three days it's it's
been going on a lot longer than that
it'll be fine you think so yeah it's
gonna happen do you think this war loads
what is gonna have ten blocks and then
11
and then he's going to take over all of
washington i mean he's going to run out
of men
they have guns okay that's the problem
the problem is they're openly carrying
rifles inside this six block
i know but they need to eat okay and
then no supplies are gonna get in that
seven blocks they're just gonna wait
them out
or they're gonna come in with superior
firepower and
it's not gonna end well joe i don't
think it's gonna end well i'm just i
don't
know how it's gonna end all right let's
let's send it let's guess
the scenario okay all right how many
bodies what's the overall
four people die how many are there how
many of them are there
thousands i think thousands and you're
only going with four
that's a good number that's like a vegas
number we like [ __ ] they always pick the
perfect do i go over i go under this
the price is right i don't know how many
[ __ ] people are in there but the
photos that i saw the place is packed
filled with people like like they're
just getting out of a chappelle show
look at this
these are the people they took city hall
oh they took city hall they owned city
oh now now most of them are white so i
don't see the staying power of this
wait what did you just say they opened
the door for them
they gave them city hall so this is city
hall they're walking into right now yeah
this is
yeah well this is going to be funny now
when they get in and they don't know
what to do let me hear some volume on
this jamie you want to hear what the
[ __ ] they're yelling
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the laugh factory in long beach got
looted last night
oh god i can't imagine how many puppets
they took
is there puppets in the live factory
there's these giant creepy [ __ ]
mannequins i've that place is
it's you know i love that place i love
performing there but some of the jamie's
decor
i love my favorite things to do in this
business is [ __ ] on jamie masada he
knows i love him
buddy bill burr bad black lives
matter buddy don't burn down my club yes
please buddy
this business has always been weird like
that there's always no that's why you're
the king
dude because you got outside of it but
you're totally in it and they can't
they can't get you they can't get you i
i you know
i'm piling up some stories here being in
the matrix
i won't get into them but it's the same
it's just the
same old corporations only know how to
do business
one [ __ ] way well just they push
their advantage
they push their advantage they have
their leverage and they want the biggest
slice of the pie that's that's what they
do i don't have a problem with that it's
when they go beyond that and they just
straight up steal
are they stealing from yeah everybody
does every time you get in business with
like corporate guys this is how it works
it's like the check
okay we're in business to make money
from them and then you get in business
with them and then the check goes to the
corporate guy
and then you get your cut off of his
checkbook
so right there i am immediately in a
situation where there's no way i can
steal from him but he can
rob me [ __ ] blind right and you can
add a bunch of expenses onto things that
front end load expenses to make it look
like they're losing money
and yeah it's hollywood accounting yeah
no it's stealing
it's stealing is what it is they just
call it hollywood accounting but it's
not hollywood accounting it's it's
corporate accounting
it's scumbag accounting that's just and
it's how they do it and they sleep at
night and they always ask
oh that's over in the accounting section
of the building not over here where me
and my yacht
are i'm like artist friendly you know i
majored in
[ __ ] liberal arts in college well
what was really interesting
when podcasts started to take off they
started to try to get in with the old
model
and weasel into podcasts and and buy
pieces of podcasts and like if you code
your deal
if you think the [ __ ] industry is
going to sit back when they didn't get
to wet their beak on that thing
i'm going to tell every young comic when
we get back to this [ __ ] is
what they're going to do now is what the
music industry did well they started
signing straight across the board deals
they're going to get some young kid
who's got no power in the business and
it's just like you know we'll help you
create a podcast
you know we're signed with so-and-so
blah blah what they're going to do is
they're going to own the podcast the
advertising money's going to go to them
and they're going to rob them
[ __ ] blind 100 they're going to 100
100
gonna [ __ ] steal from them rob them
[ __ ] blind
and then when they get audited and they
get caught stealing
they're going to label that kid that
young comic difficult to work with
meaning difficult to steal from
that's it's already happening yeah uh i
know guys
who young guys i won't name any names
but they've come up to me and go hey
um i'm signed to this management company
they want to sign me
but they want a piece of my podcast no
they want a piece of this
and they they want it there's no reason
there's no reason yeah
you got to tell people that dude because
you're the k you got to tell all right
you got to tell people do not don't give
up anything
don't give up anything don't ever it's
all you they're not going to do anything
for you they think what they're going to
do is move the ball
quicker that first [ __ ] two years and
then the rest is all going to be you if
you just hang in there
and and struggle a little bit like you
got to grind you just got to hang in
there and keep going i mean i got a lot
of offers to buy half of the podcast or
to buy p and i
nothing i wouldn't i won't i won't do it
i'll never do it but then
spotify came along and they said we'll
give you a licensing deal
so just put it on our network for three
months but you still own it right like
all right we're in
and that's that's why we did it that way
but this this comic that i won't name
he was telling me that is this
management company they wanted to sign
him they wanted to own
a piece of his podcast forever and what
that will eventually
become yeah because what they're going
to look at it is they're going to make
it like
if you started a podcast while you wish
this manager or why you're with this
agent it'll be like back in the day when
you booked a sitcom exactly
and then if you left the agency or the
manager throughout the lifetime
of that sitcom you owed the commission
to them exactly but back then
that you needed them to do that you
don't need them for the podcast but
they're going to do that so then
you're going to leave this manager and
then for the rest of your [ __ ] life
you're going to be paying this
never-ending alimony yeah i mean
there'll be guys eventually they'll try
to take 50
60 i own your podcast managers will
start
agents will start podcast networks
because there's nobody
regulating them to not do that anymore i
got an offer just
five years ago from a company that was a
radio company
that wanted 50 of the podcast they were
going to give me no money they wanted 50
of the podcast just to be associated
with them and like we're going to
pull together all these advertisers and
it's going to help your revenue no
50 percent
they gut the thing well the beautiful
thing about podcasts is podcasts all
get big on word of mouth like i've never
advertised this podcast i never did
anything with it right i never bought
billboards or put ads up anywhere
it's just from word of mouth and the way
other podcasts grow
is people get on people's podcasts and
they say hey
you listen to bill burr's podcast monday
morning podcast [ __ ] hilarious
and then it just grows and i think it's
the job of people making money and
podcasting to let new podcasters know do
not sign those deals
ever do not let the fox into the hen
house because they are going to [ __ ]
rob you blind and you don't need it and
i i saw this documentary one time on
this heavy metal band
anvil right this crazy thing about this
band that just was around forever and
never quite made it and there was a i
think it was i think it was
that one it's one of those ones about an
old like metal band from the 80s and
this guy said
like the truest [ __ ] ever when he was
talking about the music business and
this goes straight across podcast
everything he goes you're better to own
something 100
and only sell 20 000 copies than you are
to uh not own it at all and sell 20
million like you're literally going to
make more if you just sell 20
20 crazy yeah no they [ __ ] because and
then another thing that they do oh my
god dude another thing that they do is
then
the all the people that they lose on
they dump that on you yes
yes like i remember one time i forget
what
i i was uh with this network and i had a
cd that was already made
i already made it and i just wanted them
to put it out on their label
and they and they wanted to own the cd
and i was like no i'm not no i don't
want you to own it i just need you
to to like distribute it i need you as a
distributor and the guy said to me he
goes well you know ownership shouldn't
be that big a deal for you
it should be about exposure i said all
right well let me ask you this
if ownership shouldn't be that big a
deal to me why is it such a big deal to
you
and he started like stammering and then
he basically said well you know
we get in business with something he
named a couple of the comics whose cds
didn't sell
and we have to recoup those losses it's
like that ain't my fault that's
hilarious i could have told you not to
sign that [ __ ] jerk off what is your
it's not my fault you didn't do the
[ __ ] work
so that's the way i had another one one
time i signed
this back when i made like cds and i did
one and i had a 60 40. you get you know
i was getting 60 and they were getting
40.
but their 40 was off the gross mine was
off the net
and all expenses for the album was on me
it's like i thought we were doing this
together
every [ __ ] thing the artwork printing
it all of that all of those expenses
came to me and in the end
that 60 40 60 uh net 40 gross
they made way more money than i did it's
just how they you're like oh okay well
i'm getting six dollars on every 10.
yeah plus the but anything it's just
hilarious that they would come up to you
and tell you that we did some deals with
some other comics did i get in business
one time to make this tv show and the
[ __ ] guys
sends this the the bill for the whole
[ __ ] thing i shouldn't be saying but
this is a while ago right
the guy was gonna bill us 2500 bucks a
month to use his copier machine
and did you then another i don't know 4
500 bucks to use his editing that's like
dude we have both of those things we
don't need those
let's take that money and put it on the
screen we're trying to get this thing to
go and
and the guy like he oh it's a funny [ __ ]
ever he goes like
i'm insulted by those questions or
something like that which is my favorite
thing ever
the the the offend like the uh what is
the like
the the i don't know you're a [ __ ]
thief and you actually have the audacity
to be like taken aback like like fanning
yourself like i can't believe you just
think it's how many [ __ ] shows are
you charging 2 500 bucks a month
to go you know [ __ ] use your copy
machine
yeah that's a lot of money that's rent
for a nice apartment
no [ __ ] thieves copy machine
how much does it cost to use that copy
machine really first of all the copy
machine probably doesn't even cost 2 500
bucks
probably renting it yeah probably rents
it for a couple hundred bucks a [ __ ]
month but even to buy a car
he probably has nine shows paying 2500
bucks a month for him to go heavy
heavy that's it if you have like a
really big one one of those commercial
grade copy machines what does it cost 10
grand
i mean how much could it cost i mean
that
i i think he's bought a couple of houses
off of owning that
copier machine and i just i just love
telling these [ __ ] stories because
these are the things that you like
what's great about podcasting is you can
say this this is for every
person out there who has a [ __ ]
business
and you know there's that thing where
you want to take it to the next level
and then these these guys come in and
then they're all just like yeah well hey
we're gonna
take a piece of it and they take a big
[ __ ] chunk out of it and what they do
is their risk is all the way down here
yours is up here and then somehow
they just i'm telling you like you're
better
you're better to sell 20 000 copies own
it 100 than
20 million and not own any of it because
you're gonna make more money that's just
how the game is played and those [ __ ]
guys who steal from people they they
sleep very comfortably
but it's also just podcasts just the
stress of dealing with other people's
eliminated
just the stress of dealing with
production people slows it down
it slows it down it slows it down it's
awful yeah i mean
the only thing spot spotify's ever done
so far
is ask do you know who the first guest
will be
and already i'm like yeah like they're
gonna be who they're gonna be
you know they're gonna be great i'm
gonna try to get my best friend funniest
people that's them justifying their desk
like i can't just sit here like joe
knows what he's doing
any idea well so uh i'd like to start a
uh email chain
and uh we could maybe circle back later
and uh have a conference call
and they're just trying to fill up there
yeah just kind of
use time yeah but the spotify people
have been great they literally said we
don't want to do anything we want you to
just do what you're doing
just do what you're doing oh but even
asking me who the guest's going to be i
was like oh no
please let this be the only question
yeah i'm never available and that's
nothing though that's nothing i mean
they're great
but could you imagine if you were doing
that with a network like imagine if you
were in business with
abc or something like that and they were
they were helping produce your podcast
you'd have to go in for meetings
you'd have to go and sign into the
office bill you sign in here you go and
sit down and waste your [ __ ]
afternoon having some dopey conversation
you kind of complain a lot when you read
these letters
bill um do you have to when people are
signing the emails maybe it should be
can we get a reread on the blah blah
what do you think how do you feel about
product placement because we've gotta
got a great deal with coca-cola
look i just wanted to i just wanted to
tell a few of those for younger people
out there because
it actually really bothers me that
people do that to people
yes it really bothers me and i love
comics and i love seeing new comics
coming up that have talent
and i hate seeing them get [ __ ] over
so hopefully
uh people listen and they do it but
they're [ __ ] worms man
they're wearing worms there's a lot of
worms out there and there's a lot of
worms that try to grab comics
real that they're talented but real raw
and they try to lock you up some
enormous lifetime management deal and
and when
you take off and you have something say
if you're dude i remember back in the
day when everyone when when
companies were like shooting specials
before comics started shooting them
and the amount of guys that got that
yeah we only got enough money for
to shoot one you know to only you can
only shoot it one time but you're gonna
crush it man you got this hour down we
only got enough in the budget
and then they'd show up early and they'd
be shooting another comic special
off their money the deal to double them
as a management company what they would
get or or an agency
the amount of [ __ ] times that that
happened with the same audience
i mean yeah yeah oh do you want to be
the best one i ever heard jim brewer
was filming a special sold out this
theater
and the the people that were filming the
special told him that the money for the
ticket sales
was theirs because it was all about the
production
because the money that people are paying
for the production he's like
the [ __ ] are you talking about this is
my audience
like that's my money his management
tried to steal
the money from ticket sales and say that
it went towards production
went all the way to court with it his
managers on their way to court has a
[ __ ] panic attack
goes to the hospital like the whole
thing's a nightmare
i think she won yeah of course he won
yeah he won well it's
thievery it's thievery like these are
tick people are paying
to see a million
of those [ __ ] stories and that this
but this is the thing this is what kills
me
about a lot of this this rhetoric that's
going on out there which i agree with 90
of it but if you if you agree with a
hundred percent of it like you and i are
not supposed to be having stories like
this
we're supposed to be the ones doing it
and it's just like you have what do you
mean
like as far as the uh the whole you know
oh you're a white male heterosexual
you know doors just fly open and people
like hey what are your dream they
like i'm i'm not saying and i'm not
obviously not bitching but i'm just
saying that like
like people will [ __ ] you it's all about
money they don't
they don't give a [ __ ] and they and they
all those people that do that [ __ ]
really yeah so there's a long history of
hollywood accounting there's a long
history of that i mean there's been so
many stories about people who made
killer hit movies and never got paid
because hollywood's like look you know
we had this much had to go to
advertising and this is the production
look how bad elvis got [ __ ]
oh yeah elvis got [ __ ] so bad and then
one of the main
ways he got [ __ ] on the road he he
only did one out of the country date i
believe he did toronto
and he never traveled the world because
his manager had something going on with
his visa and he was worried if he left
he wouldn't be able to come back
so that kind of like [ __ ] him elvis
out of a ton of [ __ ] money and seeing
the world or whatever the [ __ ] he might
have wanted to do keep doing these
movies elvis
you want to go on the road that is
hilarious well
you know the best version of breaking
down how corrupt the music business is
was by courtney love
they said she had a ghost writer i don't
know but she did but it was it's a it's
a great
article that she wrote documenting
exactly
how much you get paid versus how much
money gets generated
and where it all goes and how they [ __ ]
you yeah
no it's it's they've always done it that
way i mean that's that's
always the way they've done it that's
the chance young people that's the
answer to it
is well i mean that's how that's how
it's done so whatever i don't want to
[ __ ] sit here bitching the whole time
are you done i quit but i i smoke like
one or two
uh a month
oh god damn it joe oh i got these from
mike binder
they're good what yes wow look at that
well i guess i didn't quit today did i
come on billy funtime are we doing this
yes let's do it all right come on we got
to celebrate you had a kid
yeah you have to there you go it's my
birthday yesterday oh that's right happy
birthday thank you you're 38 again
52 brother holy [ __ ] that's me too 52
pickup
is that a weird number like like you say
it doesn't seem real
well i think in your 50s nothing matters
until the odometer flips to 60. and then
you're just like [ __ ]
yeah i know 60 guys in their 60s
yeah sorry guys in their 60s is this the
ted nugent one look at this with the
[ __ ]
that's a serious one that's from uh uh
benchmade knives
it's an awesome knife company that gave
me a good uh cigar cutter
[Music]
you sound like bill murray in [ __ ]
what about bob which i just watched the
other day you know what he's easy
movie that's a perfect movie
when he's [ __ ] eating we did a
family movie night basically every day
the pandemic
it was uh
first couple of uh first couple of
months
basically every night we watched a new
movie watch every single adam sandler
movie
watch groundhog day again i forgot how
good groundhog day was
[Laughter]
these are delicious hmm shout out to
mike binder
yeah they're really good
anyway anyway but podcasting is fun yes
look it's a great business i mean i
started off because i was kind of
depressed because i had to move here
from uh
moved back here from colorado i thought
i had escaped i thought i was gone
it's like i'm out [ __ ] la i can't take
this crowds and everything i want
peace and i want the wilderness to live
in the mountains
i remember that and then you had to like
have a glock when you went out to go get
your mail so you didn't get eaten by a
[ __ ] bobcat or something
mountain lions yeah yeah i saw one in
the yard
like that so that could be an issue
i know that's basically a middleweight
tiger
it's a welterweight welterweight 150
pounds 147
a welterweight tiger
it's away boxing at least welterweight
mma is 170.
yeah yeah it's a weird animal to see in
the woods too because you know if that
thing runs at you like you
literally have no chance they're scared
of you though they don't want nothing to
do with you for the most part
if they if they're really hungry and
really old they'll [ __ ] you up
that's why i i i try to tell you know
my wife when i whenever you're outside
i'm like mama bear is next to the cub
always always i go there's coyotes and
they're getting bold because everyone
was inside
yeah and they come down every night
looking for a little dog or a little
[ __ ] cat you hear that [ __ ] going
down
mm-hmm in the hills everywhere like you
know once two ice suits you're just here
which is basically the dog like what the
[ __ ] is that you know
[ __ ] brutal yeah it's gross it's gary
because a little little cleanup crew
that goes around and catches animals
slipping in the backyard
yeah i don't understand people let
little dogs out because those [ __ ]
coyotes they'll figure out a way in
oh yeah well they're very smart they
they you know they have to survive they
figure out a way
yeah little creepy [ __ ] yeah they are
little creepy [ __ ] right there
everywhere can i have your city
can i promote this movie f is for family
too f is for family
season four it's coming out tomorrow
tomorrow i got two big things coming out
and then that's it i'm dried up
because everybody interviews it what's
next for you after these two things
that's it's it
it's it's the pandemic are you gonna
start going on the road at all
ah clubs are opening up yeah i'm gonna
see how you guys do
you know who comes back with a cough i
let you guys walk towards the atom bomb
that they just i mean i got a little one
at home so
i think i'm going to chill until like
september unless
it's just wide open i'm by chill i mean
if if things go well i'm going to uh i'm
going to try to do some shows at the
troubadour because i know that they're
hurting and that's one of my favorite
venues all these bands that i love have
played there
troubadour on santa monica yeah so
they're kind of they they're in you know
they're in a bad way because of this so
i'm gonna try to do a little run of
shows down there you know are they
available you can do that
not available yet but when they are
available i'm gonna try to do like a
three-night thing down there you know
work for free
get the rust off have people pay for
tickets buy a bunch of booze and some
troubadour t-shirts
and keep that place going man that's
great yeah i'll do that
yeah well i'll do that too let's do it
i'll do it yeah that sounds like fun
yeah i went there uh twice this year i
saw everlast there and i saw sturgeon
simpson yeah and steve
steve martin opened for richard pryor
there wow i
read this great steve martin article
where he was talking about uh
opening for him there so it also has
like some comedy
history there well when i was there i
was saying this is a perfect venue for
comedy it's like 500 seats
it's awesome it's got a balcony it could
be a great place for stand up
yeah it's the stores neat the store
needs help too everybody needs help
improv needs help well i know the store
is going once they can open up i know
that they're going to be fine
so uh because i'm going to be down there
all the time anyway yeah
um so as far as um
i think between now and september if
they start opening things up there's a
bunch of little theaters that are around
um that i would just you know pop in and
do a night like i said just work for
free
have the people pay you know whatever
for some tickets and buy whatever
they're selling there you know knock
them out
yeah get you know because i'm not gonna
have people pay full price
i mean i haven't taken this amount of
time off since i started
yeah you know i'm like my last gig was
uh
march 10th the dean del rey bond scott
tribute dude you should have come down
for that man i couldn't i had another
thing i had
it looked like a lot of fun dean [ __ ]
murdered the band murdered it was
[ __ ] and we had a great comment he's
got
a crazy voice he does it really sneaks
up on you because he'll sing in the car
you're like okay but then you see him
when he's in with the band
and and the microphone and everything ah
when that video that you guys put on
instagram or him singing a whole lot of
rosie i was like
holy [ __ ] he's really good
well he did it for like 15 20 years you
could tell
yeah yeah i mean he's legit yeah yeah
that was a good time
and then it was over
[Laughter]
and then it was over yeah strange
yeah i got some gigs lined up i'm gonna
announce them next week
but uh i'm gonna i'm just gonna hit the
road do some [ __ ] clubs
knock the rust off it looks like the
store is uh
not listed as a bar it's listed as an
entertainment a live entertainment venue
because they're opening up bars and
restaurants and all these different
things
and the store they kind of they tried to
label it as a nightclub
but uh peter shore is like it's like
it's not a nightclub nobody no one's
milling around you stan you sit down
you go in and sit down it's more like
right so what do they need to be
classified as to open up well they need
a different distinction for comedy clubs
they don't really have one
and you know there's a good argument a
real good argument that comedy club
should be some sort of essential
business
because people need to blow off some
steam it feels good it's
really good for you look if i was a a
guy working a regular job and i was used
to going to the store every couple
months uh
knock some you know knock some laughs
into me i mean i'd be
[ __ ] chomping at the bit to go see
some comedy right now oh i think they're
gonna be packed i remember i was in new
york
you know uh during 9 11 and i was like
is anything ever going to be funny again
and it was like a
you know like a two-week lull and then
they were just [ __ ]
packed yeah and it was actually became
almost like a second
like boom or whatever um
way back in the day i'm worried about a
second wave of the corona i'm worried
about them locking things down someone's
got to step in and stop them from doing
that
next next wave you guys got to be
proactive you got to do something about
people's immune systems you got to
lock down old people and sick people let
regular people do whatever the [ __ ] they
want you can't
you can't just lock people's freedom
down for something that killed a small
fraction of what you thought it was
going to kill
the whole thing is it's just [ __ ]
creepy to have guys like mayor garcetti
be in charge of telling people whether
or not they get to work
like that's not what the government are
supposed to be that's not they're trying
to
but they're they're trying to look out
for your best interest and trying to get
400 million people to all pull in the
same direction it's it's [ __ ]
it's you can't get 40 comics to pull in
the same direction so they have like an
impossible
they didn't they didn't there was those
people [ __ ] right
the whole [ __ ] time there's been
[ __ ] [ __ ] on my street
walking around no masks you know not
quarantining like the people that come
by the houses you see the [ __ ]
you know the same people that were going
in and out of the house who are not part
of their family still going in and out
of the house you want people to walk
down the street with a mask on
let's not start this job do you though
let's not start this okay let's get
started
i don't want to start this [ __ ] i'm
not going to sit here with no medical
degree
listening to you with no medical degree
with an american flag behind you smoking
a cigar
acting like we know what's up better
than the cdc
all i do is i list i watch the news once
every two weeks i'm like
mascara no mess still mask all right
mask that's all i give a [ __ ] about
i don't care but even they say you
shouldn't wear a mask unless you're
treating a coronavirus patient the world
health organization yeah they didn't say
that initially they didn't say it
initially no they didn't they did and
then it gradually then it grabbed and
then wait wait wait and then everybody
wore the [ __ ] masks
this is like rollerblading everybody
[ __ ] rollerbladed and then there was
that one [ __ ] homophobic joke and
then everybody acted like they never did
it
and then a hundred million [ __ ]
rollerblades got thrown into the [ __ ]
ocean
we all wore math and then all of a
sudden people are [ __ ] sitting there
what you don't have the body type for it
dude your [ __ ] knuckles would scrape
on the ground
even with that extra two inches
i just love how wearing a mask became
like this [ __ ]
like soft thing that you were doing like
being courteous being courteous why is
it for [ __ ]
oh god you're so tough with your [ __ ]
open nose and throat
joe and your five o'clock shadow this is
a man right here ah man doesn't wear a
mask
why does it always become like that it's
always like the man
what do men do we make fun of things
anything anything that uh seems like
you're not taking chances
right that's we don't have that problem
with that unless you were already
wearing the mask and then you're acting
like you didn't then all of a sudden
people watch your thing
and then they all pile up ooh look at
this [ __ ] wearing the mask it's like
you were [ __ ] doing it two weeks ago
well i was scared out of my mind in the
beginning
in the beginning like when the first
when when everybody's shutting down the
beginning and
people are stockpiling food i was
convinced i was like jesus christ dude
you have like nine elk in your basement
you were
you were the one person i knew was fine
tom pop is making bread plenty i knew
i knew he was what i was worried about i
was worried about people i knew getting
really sick and dying and then i was
convinced that i had it
at one point i was like i do feel like
i'm breathing heavy
i feel like my breath is something like
my breath is coming short
i did i did i like had like
psychosomatic yeah
guy had a [ __ ] panic attack sitting
on [ __ ] 12 elk
you had a [ __ ] panic attack and
that's honestly then you felt bad about
yourself
and then you attack people with masks
that's how it works that's how the
hatred starts and that's right now why
seven blocks of seattle you can't go now
i'm gonna go and i'm gonna drop off free
food for those folks those fine protests
there's a major american city where
seven blocks the people have took over
it and i had no idea what you were
talking about so
anything that i said i don't watch it i
envy you at all
i envy that that you just do that you
just shut everything down
me i every day i check what part of the
world's on fire i don't like
hysteria i don't like making decisions
with hysteria
and i'd like i i when i first became a
dad
the hysteria of other parents i would
just
i would be looking at them but i wasn't
listening because
that's all that was the tone of
everything we're saying you know better
get some sleep now
and you'll be like and then anytime you
say anything positive about your kid how
old's your kid
seven weeks oh yeah how is ah she's
great she's great oh
wait till seven and a half weeks it's
like
it's like dude maybe you suck at it yeah
how about that
yeah you're sitting there with your
[ __ ] legs trembling right all nervous
and [ __ ]
yeah i i don't i don't like you know i'm
already [ __ ] in the head
i'm already [ __ ] in the head i don't
need 24-hour news now
like who's that guy on fox news i always
joke with neil tucker
he's got great hair but horrible points
like if his points were as good as his
hair
which guy he looks like a kennedy i mean
he's just
he is the white guy's white guy he was
talking about black people going
and when they come for you and they will
they're gonna you know it's just like
what
are you [ __ ] talking about hannity i
don't know who he is no it's not hannity
hannity was the guy who they they put
with that [ __ ]
that that like rooster at the end a
chick in the end of his life looking guy
like here's your liberal dude and all my
relatives who are conservative like i
mean look at him i mean he's so
meek it's like this thing is cast like a
show
yeah who was that guy that he was with
henry and combs
and though the one guy looked like he
was on death's door and he was
delivering he was great yeah he was
great and the other guy looked like a
football hero
astronaut with the square face nice
[ __ ] head of hand
another guy you look like mr burns right
yes and he had no spine he had no it
wasn't
strong arguer i was he was there he was
he was the washington generals
and the other guy was the globetrotters
and then and then you put on cnn
you got all those [ __ ] nitwits with
the situation room and all of that
this is why i wish that there was a
comedy club because
there's a bit that's already come and
gone was what i loved
was when uh uh colin kaepernick when he
was taking a knee right
all the liberals were just like well hey
man it's just like his opinion man you
need
wait this is a time to listen man and
then
everybody on the right's like shut the
[ __ ] up and play football you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] don't disrespect the flag
right
and then drew brees tweets something
conservative
and then all of a sudden everybody on
the right's like hey man
this is just like his opinion man and
then everybody left like you [ __ ]
racist piece of [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ]
cancel you
they literally do this everybody
believes in like freedom of speech as
long as you're saying what they want to
[ __ ] hear
is basically and that's why i [ __ ]
hate both of those news channels
uh yeah i i i it actually devices if
it makes my blood boil when i walk into
a house
with people i know if they're watching
cnn or fox like i can't get past the
like
when people watch like the kardashians
it's like why would you do that to your
brain
it is what it's like i mean
it's very toxic it's very toxic both
sides and
they they they never see any good points
that the other side is making and every
video on the internet
starts after the thing happened
and it's like you're always like it's
like you're getting eight episodes in
and you're like what the [ __ ] it's like
you don't know what's
like if you watched the last scene of
josh you're like why the [ __ ] did he
kill that shark
[Laughter]
there's enough sharks dying out there
you didn't see that this thing was
specifically targeting human beings and
he needed to do this
right how does that relate to the news
i'm saying when you watch the news
people don't like they're not filming
what leads up to whatever [ __ ]
confrontation happened right
okay so you're getting a very skewed
you don't know what happens what they're
saying happens
could be what happened or a bunch of
other [ __ ] i don't
i don't i don't understand oh i'm
supposed to watch something
you know like this there's obviously
obviously like that [ __ ] minneapolis
was the most obvious [ __ ] ever that
guy's a murderer and those other three
guys sat around and just watched him
[ __ ] do it
when guy's calling out i can't breathe
and all of this [ __ ] and calling out for
his mother was [ __ ] sickening that
guy's a monster had the audacity to have
a shocked look on his [ __ ] face
that guy's terrible right but like what
i'm saying is
that thing had all of this he kind of
got
the whole [ __ ] thing when they came
up you had the whole thing
there's so many other and i'm not just
i'm not talking about cop stuff i'm just
talking about
anything taking a a little piece of
somebody's
stand-up routine or a politician says
this
or voted he voted no on this and what it
is is this [ __ ] that
all it's usually the [ __ ] that was
attached to it
which is something i don't understand
with politics like why can't you just
vote
on what you're voting on like should we
have clean water
yes we should and then like the [ __ ]
that's attached to it but we
dump toxic [ __ ] in here and then when
the guy goes to or the woman goes to
run it's like oh this this person voted
against the clean water act
this is your tree hugger i'm joe blow
and i approve of this message well
here's
here's a good version of that remember
the covington school case
there was the the kid had a maga hat on
and the native american was
beating the drums the kid was smiling
looking at him and they took it
pretending that this kid walked up to
this native american beating the drums
and was smiling in his face and mocking
him
what really happened is these kids were
on a field trip for high school
they're selling maga hats the kids are
16 they're being jerk offs they buy
these hats and put them on they're just
having fun
right very little supervision while
they're there
these native americans are beating their
drums and this guy walks up to the kid
and gets in the kid's face
and is beating the drum now cnn all
these people went with his narrative
these kids were mocking them
the kid just stood there smiling while
this native american got in his face but
the photo
is disturbing that those you know there
used to be rules on ownership of media
yeah i think way back in the day there
was like a rule of sevens like no one
person could own seven
any combination of radio tv because you
can literally influence public opinion
and that's why
like i've watched and i i dude 12 years
ago i went down the federal reserve
[ __ ] rabbit hole i became a [ __ ]
the guy you didn't want to talk to
about the federal reserve all of that
[ __ ] the problem is this federal is the
federal
express i want that island yeah all of
that [ __ ]
and like watching i just i just feel
like in the last i don't know
how many years where it's just all of a
sudden they stopped being just sort of
everything they were i think reporting
was always perverted to some level
um and now it's just it's just you're
sort of watching like op-ed pieces so
i don't know this is somebody who
doesn't watch anything and reads like
you know
autobiographies of football players in
the 1950s so when this covington school
kid case
they sued the kids sued and won they you
know the cnn paid them out to be a
monster they were getting death threats
did they did cnn else uh issue a
retraction i don't know what they did
but they paid him i don't i don't know
what they but that's why i don't i don't
like
either one of those channels because of
that and it causes i think rational
people
like that guy the guy the fat dude on
the bicycle suit
ripping those pieces of paper all those
girls hands oh yeah
jesus yeah that guy that is the result i
think of watching one of those channels
24 7 and then going on facebook and
writing in capital letters could you
imagine if you were there watching that
guy rip
pace piece pieces of paper out of a
little girl's hand like that that he
didn't even know
yelling at her running up to her where
the mother is yelling you stop touching
her
get your hands off her i would have oh
that was the mom i thought that was a
friend
whoever that was it sounded like a woman
it sounded like a woman
yelling because there's he was doing
everything but growling
yeah and then because then it gets to
the point of like what is in your head
that you're trying to defend like what
like that's a guy but then
everybody vilifies the guy which i would
rather sit down and talk to that guy and
be like let me ask you this when you
watch that
you know floyd video like
what is it that you see because just
yelling at somebody cancelling him and
making him lose his [ __ ] job you're
just gonna make the guy even more angry
and he probably has grandkids that he's
going to fill their head before before
he dies
so what's the solution sit down talk to
him
i think that should be part of it like
buddy let's just
sit down for a second you were on a
bicycle you wanted to burn some calories
you're obviously into it by the way
you're dressed okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're enjoying america's great parks
right
you come across these kids you know do
you like kids
have you ever attacked a kid before if
they're just putting a piece of paper up
with the point of view like what what do
you think
led up to that level of a response
because i have to be honest like we've
all [ __ ] snapped
and done [ __ ] i would like to think i
have and afterwards i'd be like what the
[ __ ] why did i argue that why did i say
that why did i do that
and the only way to uh
kind of prevent from you being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] again is you have to kind of
walk back and look at it
right so going at the guy which i
totally understand
because it was it was so bad it was
almost comical
because he was a borderline growling at
them and uh
it was really bad he didn't even get the
paper from the girl grabs the girl the
girl
clenched her fist down and held onto the
paper my favorite part was the sound of
his
the bottom of his shoes that clip into
the pedal thick
he sounded like a little show pony
he was trying to growl like a tiger and
he sounded like my pretty pony like
somebody should have been uh
combing his hair so and i was sitting
there going look at this crazy old guy
and uh okay i don't know how
i didn't think how old i thought he was
but then he was like 60 i was like this
guy's like only eight years older than
me
so he graduated high school like eight
years before me so like this guy is
almost part of my generation like
what experiences did he have that he
looks at this whole thing like um
you know i mean i'm not of that that
that thing is saying all cops are like
those guys it's like no it's like you
have to get those guys
off of the force that's what i think so
um i just don't understand like
and that was my understanding what they
were putting up there was specific to
the
minneapolis case so my thing is as a
human being how could you have
issue with somebody trying to put
something
up you know honoring that guy or
something positive
about that like that's what i was
confused i don't know what she put up
i'm not sure what she put up it was
definitely
about the george floyd protest
you know maybe that's a great point i
couldn't see what was written on the
paper and i just i
filled that in when i watched it but i
really couldn't get over the sound of
his shoes though
that was really [ __ ] funny and when
he started walking faster with the bike
it was almost like a great movie trailer
for a horror film
yeah no but could you make a 60 year old
fat bike ride imagine if that was your
daughter so i mean
your daughter you're sitting there and
that guy runs up to your daughter and
he's grabbing the paper out of her hand
he's running at her grabbing the paper
while a woman screaming at him to not
touch her don't you touch her
yeah i mean imagine yeah i mean there's
only one response as a father
yeah murder yeah yeah i don't like
murder no what do you like meme
i want him to remember that he did it
that's interesting
that's interesting that's another level
start with the blown out acl
and you go from there yeah beat him with
his stupid shoe
why do people wear i actually have i
actually had to look up why people wore
those shoes they clip
in i know they do but i'm like what is
the advantage of that
is there an advantage yeah i think i
think it's when when you're coming up
this way
oh you can you can still pull with your
legs so you're getting more of an
efficient emotion this guy's really been
this guy's really
into uh biking biking and not putting
paper on trees
don't put their dead relatives in their
faces just a man that would run up to a
little girl like that and grab her
grab paper out of her hand there he is
click click click click that's before
but that's before he grabs her jamie
yeah back it up from the beginning
because now as far as you
with your martial art background you got
to be impressed with the way he's using
his bike there
no he's sort of like trying to be a
little heard shout out to cyclists in
maryland
caught on what is this saying we want it
see right there
that's where a bison was caught on video
earlier attacking teenagers who were
posting flyers
is that a teenager it's a little girl is
that really a teenager she might be 13.
he just runs up to her yelling at her i
mean look at he's towering oh my god
look at her though good for her she yeah
see that's i think i don't know if
that's a woman or her friend
but that girl's got balls or ovaries
i like the little skip step too like a
cornerback well he's running at the guy
with the camera
and knocks him over the man achieved his
goal
okay as much as you don't approve of
what he's doing he achieves his goal no
she's still got the paperwork no i'm
just
i'm joking he grabbed her arm whatever
happened to that guy
three charges i don't know but they're
promoting my movie right there look at
that
king of staten island what are the odds
on demand everywhere friday
yeah i would be in the news
with a big old [ __ ] orange jumpsuit
on if that was
happening to my daughter oh my god be a
real problem
if i caught someone doing you would be
like a [ __ ] badger
on that [ __ ] just your biggest
problem
would be what do i use
i almost think for a half a second like
you would be you
elbow what do i want to do choke him
what do i [ __ ] do that spin and heel
kick i saw you do you i
if you ever hit me with that i have to
learn how to talk again
yeah joe it didn't happen it didn't
happen to your daughter right now you
just went to a dark
[ __ ] place there i go there all the
time bill
that's a real problem i know i do too i
go there all the time i do think getting
uh
talking about at least protest i think
something really positive is going to
come out of this because the fact that
so many white people
are also pro and getting involved in it
and so many cops were vocal saying that
you know they shouldn't do that so i
think something good
is going to come out of this i just
don't agree more i really do i do and i
hope
so too because it's it it's been wrong
for way too long and
i also hope that uh
that a bunch of other groups don't use
this as a piggyback thing
to then do some other [ __ ] which will
then
escalate we'll make people who want
things to
stay the same they'll be able to shift
focus
of like you know like how they try to
make like the protesters and the writers
like that they're the losers the same
people right right
where it's just yeah there's only yeah
you you did that and then at night you
did this
no yeah the way that so i don't you're
gonna do it anyways i think there's
the once the looting died down you're
seeing peaceful protests that are very
encouraging
i think it's great i really do i mean
that downtown la one was amazing
50 000 [ __ ] people filled the streets
and no crime
or very little nothing i heard of it was
just mostly people
chanting and holding signs yeah they
looked promising
look they kind of the the thing that
just
disturbs me is this idea that they
should defund the police you can't get
rid of the police
what you need to do is spend more money
and train them better and
have higher standards and do it the way
you do the military
where it's very difficult to get in and
you weed people out that are weak
like that guy was a [ __ ] that guy
leaning on that guy's neck like that
that guy is a monster
there's no way that guy because he knew
he was being filmed too and he just had
no yeah i mean that's like
hands in his pockets like he was just
[ __ ] you know waiting for an uber or
something like that
makes you think yeah he's a monster yeah
and that guy had been doing that forever
you know
there there's new evidence that they
worked together and they
fought they they argued about the way
that cop was treating
the customers they worked together at
security at the same club
and that cop was a [ __ ] [ __ ] to
people at the club
and they argued about it so they had a
personal issue
and there's some people that wanted to
be elevated to first-degree murder
because of that
that he did it on purpose oh he knew he
knew that guy
oh man i mean it's just yeah they argued
when they worked together apparently one
of the guys that worked with them said
that george floyd was always telling
that guy he's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
the way he treats customers because he
would mace people and [ __ ] that kind of
stuff
pepper spray folks he just was the first
guy to use violence
right away yeah escalate the city he had
a history of complaints
back to 2006 my friend joe schilling the
kickboxer i'm talking about again but
his [ __ ] page is the most disturbing
page right now
because all he's done over the last five
six days is post videos
of police brutality and it's
police brutality on black women
white women white old men black old men
young guys oh it's just just police
brutality over and over and over and
over again
there's a problem of racism in this
country for sure there's also a real
problem
with people that have the kind of power
the cops have that are weak people
that are that are sociopaths and that's
that's as much of a problem as any of
this
yeah yeah you attack the racism onto it
you got a horrible situation but those
people are psychopaths
they're monsters that guy who did you
know that reminds me a long time ago
like i haven't talked to a security guy
and he said the best guys are the guys
that
that they de-escalated yeah he goes you
don't because he this guy used to put
together crews of guys to uh
i think it was like rock concerts and
stuff and he said you didn't want to get
guys that wanted to fight you didn't
want to have those guys because those
guys would be a [ __ ] headache and
every night there was going to be
something and there was going to be
lawsuits like what
what you what he was saying you
ultimately wanted
was nothing to happen yeah so
um i remember because i was joking with
them i remember a long time ago
the grill 93 this old dick doherty room
i remember that joint
so two guys were about ready to go at it
in the club and the bouncer gets them
outside
okay and this guy's trying to say his
point of view and he put his hand on his
shoulder he goes
he goes uh he goes no all i was trying
to do he barely barely went like that on
his shirt and he goes okay first of all
don't touch me that's what the bombshell
said and just immediately it was here
and then it became then it went to here
and then those two guys started yelling
at each other and then
and within i don't know what the [ __ ] he
just twisted the guy up and took him out
and i forget who the [ __ ] i was with we
were [ __ ]
dying laughing it just became a
catchphrase between us so he would come
up hey bill you working this weekend
okay first of all don't touch me just
you just you immediately just escalated
where it just becomes a what the [ __ ]
and then
first of all don't touch me from ninety
percent of guys who's immediately gonna
put you in your ego where it's like oh
[ __ ]
now now he's on top of me and i'm the
[ __ ] i gotta i gotta
at least get a little get at his eyebrow
level
i have to come back with something else
it was inevitable the second he said
that first of all don't touch me
i did like the three slide steps down
because i learned that
young watching fights you know you don't
want to have a really good seat
because it's like a tornado you don't
know where it's going to go and you
think you think you're like 20 feet away
that meant me at a bruins game the old
boston garden
and it was like one of those you know
just everybody smoking you probably
couldn't smoke
in the garden at that point i just
remember like like smoky bars and [ __ ]
so we went in there and everybody was
hammered i was hammered drinking like
[ __ ] heifer reference remember the
green death right
like dude this is like six percent
alcohol so um
some like one of those two rows of fans
fighting which is always great because
like the people that are a row up are
just throwing down these guys
getting [ __ ] pounding there's always
a loafer laying there right
uh mike millbury picking it up so i
remember
the cops ran up there and i ran up to to
watch the fight
and they started grabbing guys and
coming down the stairs and it was the
boston guard and there was nowhere to go
and i remember this big cop bounding
down the stairs
he literally had a handful of this guy's
neck it was like his whole neck and his
jugular and this guy was different
colors
i just remember he was going to try to
try to push me down the stairs try to
push me down the stairs and he came down
like
and i was trying to get out of the way
and i figure i think the guy who he had
grabbed like his knee [ __ ] hit me in
the back
you know i just i just got caught by the
debris of this guy running by and that's
when i kind of learned like uh
you know when it to how to watch a fight
which you watch a fight and you're
looking at your exits because like i
said it's like
you don't know where it's gonna [ __ ]
go and uh i had learned that lesson so
when i saw that guy say that uh
first of all don't touch me i was just
like okay sliding over here
let some other people settle in in front
of me i can do i like doing that
yeah that's the same as if yeah you want
to be above slightly above
looking down at all the altercations
get a better viewpoint there anyway yeah
i suck at it dude i i stopped fighting
in like junior high
that was it i just i knew i i mean i
just knew i was like this is not
my thing i can't slip a punch i am slow
as [ __ ]
i got a big head i got a huge target
this is not gonna go three rounds it's
just not
um i fought up until like six around
sixth grade i think i probably had my
last one and then all of a sudden kids
started to get 120 130 140 pounds and
they started being blood
and [ __ ] people missing a couple days
of school after a beat down i was just
like you know what okay
i think i'll be the funny guy
it's weird how things go sideways like
that when there's a there's a feeling in
the air
when whenever chaos breaks out like that
and it's a real melee
there's a feeling in the air like it's
like you you feel it it's like oh this
is nuts
like this is this is really dangerous
yeah there's a a
a mob mentality feeling that you get
that's real weird
when things go crazy i remember it took
me uh having to leave
boston for about seven years i was gone
for seven years before i finally walked
into a bar and just felt
the normal energy of i think the city's
changed a lot
but like that sort of that tail end of
the the craziness i walked into a bar
and you could just feel it it's like
somebody's going to get suckered not now
it's about 90 minutes away you could
just feel the level of drunkness
the the the energy well guys would go
out looking for fights
some guys would go out looking for
fights yeah i knew there's a guy used to
train with
mike blythe he used to work at the rat
scaler he was a bouncer
he would go he would wrap his hands he
would wrap his hands on his way to work
i knew a guy i knew a guy tape his
wrists and [ __ ]
i knew a guy was a bouncer and he used
to bring a mouthpiece
so yeah to uh to work but he used to
carry it all the time
and i remember when he would get when he
would get in a fight he would [ __ ]
it was it was something where he would
it was a mothka who'd bite down it
wasn't like what you guys wear
but it would totally psych the other guy
out like he would come out and he would
just put this thing in and the guy be
like
this guy brought equipment like what the
[ __ ] is going on here
and i remember one time he got he got
suckered
he knew it was gonna be a fight and i
think well some dumb reason he sat down
on the stairs and the guy was standing
above him
and one of his friends jumped down and
just punched him and i saw the
mouthpiece it was like [ __ ] busted
douglas tyson
i saw his mouthpiece fly towards us and
then just
i shouldn't tell these stories because
why i don't know because i
you know it's my version of what it was
a long
long like names i was like 30 years ago
and what happened was we were
in an off-campus apartment and
i can't believe i tell a story i'm going
to tell the quick version uh
tell the whole version no two of my
buddies left
to go upstairs it was one of those you
know those old [ __ ] boston
it looked almost like a three family
house but it wasn't one of those big
ones that has all apartments in it right
so they left the party we were on on the
first floor and then they went upstairs
and like 20 minutes they came back one
of my buddy's shoulders was separated
the other guy
flat lip and he had a flat top too and
maybe this big [ __ ] gash
coming right down here and blood coming
down his face and we were like
what the [ __ ] happened what the [ __ ]
happened we just asked this guy for a
drink the whole party started beating on
us
so this whole mob goes up the stairs
to go fight the party right and i'm
going upstairs like what the [ __ ] am i
doing my big [ __ ] hit i'm gonna get
knocked out here
but i have to go because of my friends
so we [ __ ] go up there
and uh we hear the party so my buddy the
mouthpiece guy
like the most innocent void ever knocks
on the door he goes hey
he's like is there a party going on in
there right and the [ __ ] door opens
up and it was like a [ __ ] west
wild west movie like a saloon fight just
[ __ ] haymakers
i remember i didn't want to go in i was
so scared because i was like oh my god
this is going to be [ __ ] nuts and
just the
mob just sent me in and it was just like
everybody's just throwing i remember
this dude jumping over my back punching
me my
face right and the smoke [ __ ] clears
and it all settles you know it was all
like [ __ ] 15 second melee and it all
[ __ ] settles and we look
at the party and there's like six or
seven guys
six or seven girls and there's like a
board game that's tipped over
and we had gone to the wrong party swear
to god i know this sounds like a joke
the real party
where they got hit was upstairs
and i don't remember what happened but
they they were actually rich kids and
they sued my friends for going in
whatever the dumb [ __ ] they did oh
no we all went in to the wrong party and
they were in there
having like a couples thing and they
were playing like [ __ ] monopoly or
something and all of a sudden there was
a knock on the door hey is there a party
and then everybody just came [ __ ]
running in
imagine them that's what i'm saying no i
feel that's why i didn't want to tell
cause i felt i felt really
like yeah i felt bad when i was in high
school the first
real brawl that i ever saw was that i
was like
17 i think i was a senior in high school
and there was a rich kid that moved into
the neighborhood he wanted to make
friends
so he put on this crazy party he just
invited everybody
so kids from all kinds of different high
schools were coming no that's just good
yeah newton north newton south a bunch
of kids from all sorts of other places
and uh i happened to be at the right
place at the right time when i saw it
pop off
people were already robbing this guy i
saw people taking stuff out of bedrooms
and running down the stairs with it
it was real sketchy because there was
way too many people for this guy's part
but then this girl i still to this day
don't remember what she did she either
slapped this guy in the face
or she threw a drink in his face i don't
remember i think she slapped him
but what i remember is he uncorked a
perfect right hand on her
he know how to punch like i remember
thinking wow this guy's trained
because he's he snapped it joe always
the commentator
listen i've been doing it for a long
time but
whatever she did i'm pretty sure she
slapped him but he went like this
i mean it was a perfect right hand hit
her right in the face
her head goes back this guy behind her
catches her she's
totally unconscious and then blah
chaos chairs flying bodies piling up and
i'm on the stairs
so i'm watching this through the
railings i see the guy punch the girl
as i'm coming up the stairs i see it all
play out i'm like holy
[ __ ] and i'm like i gotta get out of
here yes and it there was pile
i didn't i didn't hit anybody and nobody
hit me i [ __ ] it was like a movie
like excuse me
crawling out i [ __ ] dodged
everything meanwhile uh i was fighting
at the time i was
traveling to tournaments all over the
country and fighting so my friends were
looking for me
they're like you know go get joe and
there's piles of people
brawling and i'm just ducking the piles
and then i ran into my friend jimmy and
i'm like where is everybody and we
gathered our friends and got in the car
and drove off we were laughing our asses
off
but it was like when we left the cops
were just starting to arrive there was
piles of
kids beating the [ __ ] out of each other
on the lawn dude i remember
my friend who separated his shoulder in
that fight we popped it back in
and he went back up threw a punch with
the same arm
and missed it came out again and i
remember him flopping on the ground like
a fish out of water
and afterwards we said to mike dude why
didn't you throw the other hand
and he goes because i wanted this hand
to get its revenge
[Laughter]
like he had made his part of his body
like a karate movie
like he had to avenge his shoulders
death
dude that's and i have to tell you
something when people
uh talk about you know you're a funny
comedian and blah blah the
characters that i grew up with and what
i loved about what they did and what
they said was they weren't trying to be
funny like he was
dead serious he wanted revenge for his
heart
yeah and then we were driving home
hammered
and we would three abreast uh in
in the [ __ ] uh the uh the pickup
truck
it was this guy's dad's truck and he had
the flat top so he's got
dried blood on his forehead and we're
just driving home and nobody's saying
anything
and the dude in the middle has got these
sunglasses on
and he's just sitting there like this
and then all of a sudden out of nowhere
he just [ __ ]
he goes like that scared the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of me
and i did i was like dude what the [ __ ]
are you doing and he goes
uh sorry he goes because i took a little
acid
he goes i was looking at this bug
he goes because i thought it was
on the windshield it goes it turned out
it was on the inside of my glasses
now i don't know if that was true but
dude there's only like
there's no way you could ever reenact
how much he flipped it like how much you
would freak out on acid if you thought
a bug was over there but then your mind
told you that it was on the inside of
your [ __ ] glasses
and i just remember all three of us just
crying laughing driving home at this
just just the whole [ __ ] situation
that was like that was like every
weekend
of my life for like um
probably like two and a half three years
every single [ __ ] weekend and we used
to go in
to uh this there was this club in uh
this bar in chelsea
oh boy yeah well i told i was such a
baby face that was the only place where
you get served right so it's a rough
place
yeah well yeah it was it was yeah and
they were like
selling uh [ __ ] blow out of there so
they didn't give a [ __ ] if you look like
you were 12 years old like i was when i
go up to uh
order my my vodka collins it was like
the only how old were you
um i wasn't of age
like 19 or 20 probably 20
and i would go in there and i just
remember one time standing outside that
bar
and there was this [ __ ] dude who
looked like rob halford from [ __ ]
judas priest just [ __ ] totally
gacked out of his [ __ ] mind standing
in front of his
motorcycle and he was telling this story
about riding his bike and
his drug thing he got stuck he just kept
saying i'm going around the apex
going around the apex go around the apex
right now i'm [ __ ] hammered
and i'm like making fun of the guy in
front of him to my buddy i'm looking at
my buddy and i'm so shit-faced i'm going
around the apex i'm going around the
apex and he's hitting me because the
guy's staring at me
yeah no it was it was a uh and i didn't
underst like
because i never did coke so i didn't
understand what was going on
i'm gonna leave it at that i didn't
understand what was going on but all i
knew was i
just seemed to be the guy that wanted to
go home first
i'll leave it at that that was a [ __ ]
dangerous place boston was dangerous
no i this is when i figured out what the
[ __ ] was going on was one time
i went into the bathroom by myself to
take a leak it was one of those things
you walk in there was a sink there was a
stand-up burner
and then there was a a stall which just
had one toilet
and i walked in and there was two
[ __ ] legs guys in there and i was
like what the [ __ ] are those guys doing
so my dick's already out i'm taking a
piss
and they open like the thing because i
didn't have a latch opened up and they
had like the
they were doing blow and i i was taking
a piss because it was weird there's two
guys in there and i kind of glanced over
as i'm already pissing
i look over and this guy's all [ __ ]
hammered like little werewolves like
what the [ __ ] are you looking at
i was just like pe
[Laughter]
didn't wash my hands after that one no
there was a lot there was a lot
i don't know why because a lot of like
like easy targets really got hit and i
was beyond an easy time somehow i just
never
i you know i never asked yeah i did i
did because i i would have got really
uh i was not as tough as my friends were
my friends were [ __ ]
lunatics you know but my you know my
great my grade was cool but like the
great above me and greater below me they
were like some [ __ ]
they were crazy i talked to friends that
grew up in other places
they would they didn't have the same
amount of fight stories
i think boston is a particularly fighty
place
fighty you know what i'm saying i don't
know what yeah
there was something going on but i mean
i think a lot of those east like new
york and uh [ __ ] this thing's going on
um a lot of those uh
like i find the people in like
new england long island tri-state area
it's all sort of the same
savages savage children of immigrants
that's what it is yeah but you go out to
the midwest and that's like german a lot
of slavic people
polish people so i mean that's i don't
know what i think they just had more
space out there
so it wasn't as intense you weren't so
like packed
yeah you're in a corn field there's
something about boston though
in particular i think even more so than
new york boston was just like a lot of
fights man
my boxing coach got his finger bitten
off on a fight
he was on pcp this guy bit his finger
off and uh
he had his toe removed and replaced
his finger with a toe did i tell you
this no i remember that was that was the
move back then
so he had it curved permanently so that
he could still throw right hooks
so his uh his when you would shake his
hand he would always give you one of
these
he was like yeah i knew a guy from
boston too he had this weird looking
nose and some guy
it bit it off and have it reattached
guys lost ears
dude that's why i'm saying why you know
it's right around sixth grade i was just
like yeah this is like becoming blood
sport like
i think i'm gonna try to be funny here
but yeah there was a lot of um
there was also a lot of you know the
sports scene back in boston
is just uh well it was was insane
yeah because hockey was big in boston
and hockey is the only sport that
involves actual fights it's the only
sport where fighting is a part of the
sport
i'm reading this book right now i'm
reading like i got three sports books
i'm reading right now right
i read a few in the lines and then i
write a couple chapters over here and
i'm reading this one called
uh bartnik gave it to me the uh called
the code
and it breaks down for anybody ever
never understood
why there was fighting which i never
quite understood either i just knew i
liked it
um it's it's and how the players have to
police the game
i i'm not far enough into the book but
it's it's really eye-opening
like what goes on out there these and
they have all these
these enforcers talking about it like
because sometimes you had to fight
sometimes guys would just skate out they
put them on just the guy being out on
the ice sometimes he'd say something
like
hey we don't settle it down out here
boys somebody's gonna get hurt a guy
would just say that and then people like
all right
okay all right let's [ __ ] sticks back
down everybody play
old-time hockey whatever the [ __ ] he was
supposed to do all-star hockey
and um just as far and then as far as
like
how there's this whole code of and
there's all these like
you know the heavy weights like a
heavyweight only [ __ ] with a heavy
weight
unless some middleweight is doing some
[ __ ] and you gave him a warning and he
didn't then he has to take a [ __ ]
beating
and if he doesn't take the beating and
turtles up that means one of his [ __ ]
teammates is going to get the beating
and then he's going to be a [ __ ]
[ __ ] in the locker room i mean it is
it is this whole web
of fascinating [ __ ] cause everybody just
looks at the sport and they just think
oh drop gloves [ __ ] beat the [ __ ] up
there's a whole
[ __ ] thing that that is going on out
there
that actually because of that it keeps
the game safer which i don't
understand i don't understand i don't
understand it either but i just think
it's fascinating that there's this one
sport where it's okay to fight
like you know what he's talking about
sport you do that's all they do is fight
that's the whole sport that's the sport
itself but
there's no fighting in basketball
there's agreed upon fighting in hockey
that doesn't exist in any other sport
where everybody backs off and these guys
go lacrosse you can do it in lacrosse
who the [ __ ] plays professional lacrosse
i i don't know but i wouldn't want to
say that i wouldn't want to say that to
one of them
this full [ __ ] cage i wouldn't say
that but those guys are savages what
about the cross-country skiers and all
of a sudden they got a rifle they're
doing like they're at a gun range i mean
that's different that's that stupid
[ __ ] what is that that's not the
decathlon you know what that's like
that's like
tex-mex food right asian infused
[ __ ] americana that's all it is it's
just people
people are you know doing their version
of cross-country skiing like that's
like yeah i like that cross-country
skiing whether you then shoot that's
like
the beginning of a lot of james bond
things they always seem to be in the
snow
yeah well the whole idea is the elevated
heart rate it's hard to control your
shot
because i think they're supposed to
shoot off-handed too you know they're
not supposed to have a rest
i know see i don't know [ __ ] about
hunting and that's the thing that i
always that i lived for on the hunting
shows
what was when the guys after the kill
and then they'd just be oh man i was so
scared
just saying all this [ __ ] [ __ ] and
it's i get it if you're shooting like a
lion
it's a nerve-wracking thing because you
don't want to [ __ ] up and you know it's
cause people are gonna make fun of you
no because you're gonna hurt an animal
you don't want to wound the animal you
want to kill it you want to kill it
cleanly it's
and you have to keep it together while
you're you're pulling the trigger on an
animal you're going to end its life
it's very nerve-wracking can't you just
give him the second one
second bullet oh he's saying if he runs
away and then suffers
if you nick it you know you shoot it in
the leg or something like that it's very
likely it's going to get away and
die slowly and get eaten by coyotes or
something
it's really bad dude i got one for you
because you got me watching those
[ __ ]
videos animals eating first of all
i love bears but i can't watch them kill
anything because they've seen the recent
one they don't bear
took down the buffalo they don't kill
them why why won't they kill they killed
it
well they just they they kill it because
they start eating it before it's dead
they just hold it down and start eating
yeah that's what bears do
i got one for you okay have you watched
the praying mantises videos
yes i have do you see the one where the
praying mantis eats the lizard who tries
to eat him
well he because he [ __ ] alligator
armed it he was like i'm gonna kill you
he kind of did the little flicky he gave
him a little jab and then that thing
just grabbed
him he was like ah what the [ __ ] yeah he
like and then he looked at him
then he started yeah but if he hit his
jaw but
if he let his hands go as you guys say
with his tongue
i think he could have pulled that thing
in and crushed him no
no praying mantis is so [ __ ] strong
they're so much stronger than you would
imagine them being because they have
these little stick arms
yeah that i watched one eat a
hummingbird oh yeah yeah
they ate all kinds of [ __ ] they ate
everything that they get a hold of we're
lucky they're
little praying mantises are amazing i
[ __ ] love those little things
they're they're crazy what they can do
to a bird or
something much larger than the lizard
was the most impressive because the
lizard thought it was going to eat him
and that thing was totally immobilized
yeah
it was like it reminded me of watching
the [ __ ] you say well he's passed his
guard yeah now he's going for this that
thing was just like oh it's exactly like
that
because the their clamp is so it's like
if somebody got you in a darce it's the
same thing someone gets like uh
like this grip and then cinches it up to
a darts choke you're like trapped in
there that's what it was like he was
there it is
this is poor [ __ ] look he thinks he's
gonna get him and
he's like [ __ ] you ain't getting
nothing but look how he holds his mouth
open
and then he's like oh dude i hate i feel
so strange
but this lizard get he gets away he gets
away for a second
but this is what's crazy second yeah
yeah yeah look at the yeah
he starts eating his mouth he just
starts sliding i know what he's doing
joe
i know he's i love it have you ever seen
uh praying mantis versus a murder hornet
you know everybody's afraid of murder
hornets look at him he's like [ __ ] what
did you do to my face oh jesus
he's like in pain he's shaking it off
and the prank man is like [ __ ] i'm not
done with you yet
like he's in agony and he's spazzing
around and the praying man is just
locks onto him again and slowly starts
pulling him apart
and at the end he's dead he just starts
eating his brain
look at that they just can pull that
skin apart and bite right through it
but it thinks so much bigger than him
that's like you eating a cow
that's like you holding a cow down no i
wouldn't do that look at that
he's eating his [ __ ] brain lizard's
dead as [ __ ]
well that that part's not a problem for
me right here because now it's dead
yeah but it died this way i know it did
that was the part i love it
i'm a big fan of the praying mantis i
like the technique
i'm not going to i just i don't need
this
the video the grizzly uh taking down the
buffalo was only two days ago it was in
yellowstone it linked me to a 30-minute
video of it just
[ __ ] up all sorts of animal
pregnancies yeah i'll put that up
by the way there's so many [ __ ]
people
there it goes what's this what's he
[ __ ] about all kinds of things
what is that it's a leaf bug i think oh
wow what a weird looking creature uh
prank oh prank mantis is pink
he's uh he's camouflaged himself
oh wow now he's the color of the leaf
yeah this is a good point
10 million views on this prank mantis
video they're amazing animals man
were you going to say were you mad about
i wasn't mad about anything i'm just
like
i you know i love bears right yes
i love when they ride the bikes at the
[ __ ] circus
[Laughter]
ride the bike in the circus oh
this is my thing about that what did
they have to do to that bear
when you see what this thing can do to a
bison what did they do to that
bear to get them to get on a [ __ ]
bicycle give them food
that's how they train them is that how
you did it you got a bear in the back
you just just the confidence the way you
said that because i've seen that
you've i've seen the train bears yeah
they can train are you one of those guys
who doesn't need any sleep like of all
the random [ __ ] things
i've seen it uh this is the one with the
best okay oh
that little whip there he's just on a
bike i don't think he freaks out
i don't think he's beating the bear i'll
tell you right now that guy's not
dressed to get a [ __ ]
to be attacked by a bear no well the
bear's got a muzzle on
and it's a little ass bear but
embarrassed dude [ __ ] you man
[ __ ] you they got the they got the
freddy krueger claws
on all he got four of them he's on a
vespa now look at that
wow i mean can you humiliate a bear even
more
he's gotta wear that frilly outfit now
you gotta didn't give him a motivation
someone who's a big fan of the bears
riding bikes i was joking
me just joking i didn't i didn't know
maybe i actually watched a whole
training video
of how like that's where do you find
what part of the internet are you on
well i don't know i was i was trying to
figure out why people uh what
the [ __ ] that guy's got a giant grizzly
bear on the back of his bike
playing a horse
on this trumpet let me hear this oh
back it up there
hello
this person that's filming this is an
idiot
you think it can't break out of that
seat belt and just
did you see the bear flipping them off
that thing has on a [ __ ] lap belt
yeah what is the beard imagine
this got to be russia right and there's
only way they would allow this is in
russia
yeah yeah look at the language in the
back of that tree he's yelling at the
[ __ ]
traffic jesus christ is [ __ ] go size
of that [ __ ] thing
my god just throwing his arms up just
thinking about ripping a person apart
no he is yeah he's thinking like i used
to be in the woods i could [ __ ] eat
whatever i wanted
the weird thing about bears is if you
train them when they're young they're
like almost like dogs
they become your buddy there was
a weird day somebody tells that bear
that it's riding [ __ ]
that guy [ __ ] that guy riding the
motorcycle
this guy he's gonna be in trouble he's
riding on the side cart
yeah he's gonna be in trouble side carts
whatever happened to those you know you
never see those a motorcycle with the
side cars you see the racing
no they do side cart racing car racing
and when they go around a turn
okay and it's on the side where the
guy's riding the side is lifted up
that guy he has to stand up dude they're
going like i don't know how many
[ __ ] miles an hour he has to stand up
and lean over all the way over on this
side of the bike because of the weight
of the sidecar
plus his way off so it doesn't yeah they
can go through the turn at a higher
speed
i mean it's bad enough when you're the
guy in the car with the map
you ever seen those when they have two
drivers yeah the one guy's yelling
turn and 100 yards left leg right left
yeah those are those rally drivers right
i never understood that do you know what
they're doing
they're yelling out directions of the
road right but they have notebooks
that tells them like what what's the
next turn next turn right next i would
guess
that the course is so long that they
they can't memorize it
or maybe it's just through a [ __ ]
town it must be yeah
this is a side car back of some of the
driver i believe
because see how he moves over there
they're going fast as [ __ ] going really
fast
oh my god you're the one who turned me
onto those bike races in the isle of man
i was supposed to go to that this year
oh you would be
side on the side oh no no no
no [ __ ] way no i i planted to
befriend some people in town
with a balcony even then like i know
some part of the bike could come
flying up but uh i want to go to that
before they outlaw it
and get out just because people die
every year
more people have died than years they've
had it whoa and it's still
like look at these [ __ ] yes
this is this is
so so more than one person dies every
year
right basically average yeah and i think
way back in the day way more people died
like the safety
equipment is much better but as you see
they're going by brick walls and trees
and like
there's just no jesus christ when you
say safety equipment like what
what the [ __ ] kind of safety equipment's
gonna save you they yeah well they have
an airbag
which is a really amazing piece of
technology whereas you fall it can tell
when you've let go of the bike and
you're falling like instantaneously and
it protects your uh
organs yeah but obviously your brain's
in the fluid so
it doesn't protect that i tell you but
the best racing out there motogp
is the [ __ ] it's better than this
um well i don't know i i
th yeah i would actually say because i
like the passing there's so much passing
what's kind of what with formula one
where mercedes and ferrari are just so
much better than everybody else
it kind of comes down to the two of them
and every year since i've been watching
since 2015 so i'm new to the sport
italian gp right here yes that's
davitzioso mark marquez i believe
you know these guys yeah wow so mark
macros the guy in second place
is like he he's the jordan of the sports
right
here davitzioso is actually in third i
don't know who's in first
so those uh that's a ducati a honda
ducati and i think a suzuki
do you ride i did for three months out
here i always wanted to ride my parents
would never let me so finally out here i
took a motorcycle safety course
i got my license and everything and then
i had a bike for like two months and it
was just
it's la is not the place to learn how to
ride and everyone was texting while
driving uh
i want to go to wyoming i think i want
to get a dirt bike
[Music]
um but this is the type of [ __ ] like
with this racing what i like is
like three or four races last year on
the final lap
there was like two guys that would pass
each other like four or five times
um like that [ __ ] right there
so then you try to come on the brakes
the l
the latest on the brakes but not
overshoot the turn i mean there's just
so much [ __ ] that's
you sort of learn as you're watching it
i still don't know [ __ ] about it but
these guys
are [ __ ] incredible would you be into
going to a track learning how to ride on
a track
that seems like the safest way to do it
absolutely that is the way to do it and
then wear all of that gear and then have
fun and you can like open up i think uh
dean sent me a video today this guy and
a porsche could go 200 miles an hour
but he [ __ ] does it on a highway and
it's just like you're going to
kill somebody or kill yourself it's like
take that thing to the track yeah don't
do that
and god forbid you hit some debris you
know what's going to happen to your car
like you
i just think i think there's a lot of
people that buy high performance [ __ ]
that
go into a track either is not available
it doesn't enter their mind
like something like myself like it
wasn't until i started watching racing
i kind of learned a little bit about him
like oh there's like a track you know
out in the inland empire
you know there's there's a day where the
like the general public can come down
and
or whatever you can pay to rent the
track and it's kind of like
you know a lot of these guys you see
driving around in ferraris if you ever
the only time i ever drove a ferrari was
i drove one on the track it was [ __ ]
unbelievable
like how hard you could stomp on the
brakes without the thing locking up
and you're trying to impress the guy
you're riding with and you think you
just want to be like
flooring it and blah blah what you
really want to be doing is smoothly
going around the smoother you go both
you know
on the gas and breaking then it becomes
like this really
like finesse thing where it looks like
you just grab it by the [ __ ] throat
and
you know like i said i only did it one
time but like i immediately learned that
like
made me appreciate what they were doing
a lot more plus
i only went around five times and my
[ __ ] brain was like
the cheap force yeah like i i almost
felt a little bit uh
like not sick i just felt a little
[ __ ] up like i think i'm gonna sit
down here for a couple of seconds
not say it to any of the guys i'm
driving with hey fine fine i could do
that all day
jimmy pull up uh porsche rally driving
the dirt road porsche drivers that's
those are the guys that are reading left
right left right
right left they have like a notebook you
need a driver next to you that's got a
notebook
that that looks like a lot of fun
apparently that's a great way to learn
how to really drive too is on the dirt
same with dirt bikes
because of the you know you slide a lot
so you learn how to counter steer
and you learn how to how to handle the
weight out back like as it's kicking out
and learning how to counter it i have
this weird thing where i am
fascinated by machines and i want
everything that i see i want to learn
how to
drive it or fly it or whatever but i'm
not a speed guy
like i'm just not into like because
you're smart
going faster i i don't know it's
dangerous i like chilling yeah these
guys see the guys there's the guy with
the book
this is a regular rope look how [ __ ]
so it's like got a digital thing telling
him what gear he's in
and here's what fascinates me is the
trust between those two guys
oh yeah like this guy this guy is
driving like a [ __ ] lunatic and this
guy's looking down at his
paper you know when your friend starts
driving like a lunatic you're looking at
him going dude dude slow down slow down
this is a road people and trees and cars
and houses on both sides
this guy's flying down this [ __ ] road
and he's going sideways all the time you
see him counter-steering all the time we
see his ass end kick
out like all the time yeah it's amazing
oh my god and how are these [ __ ]
people that are so confident they can
stand on the side of the road while
these maniacs are [ __ ]
i used to think racing was just this
stupid mindless thing and now i think
it's one of the coolest sports out there
oh it's a very cool sport
it's very i like driving cars just
to feel the mechanical just the gears
moving and all the things that are
happening
i have a an old porsche a 93 that's
no power steering it doesn't have a
radio
it doesn't have anything that's awesome
and it's all air cooled so it sounds
like
it's really mechanical have you ever
seen it i'll show it to you afterwards
that red one yeah yeah yeah yeah i wish
i had the key with me here i'd let you
drive it it's fun as [ __ ] but it's not
fast
it does it's not it's the slowest car i
have but it's fun
it's so fun to drive like you feel
everything you feel every bump
there's no nothing between you and the
wheels in terms of steering there's no
power you're steering the wheel all by
your hand it's really hard to steer
it's not that safe either yeah you can't
make quick turns like
you got to really muscle that
[ __ ] i'm like i'm into like look
at these guys
oh jesus christ but when i drive look at
these [ __ ] crazy
the guy with the propeller hat he's just
like yep i'm a [ __ ] idiot i'm
enjoying this though
look at the [ __ ] height and this guy
catches the ground with two wheels
oh my god does it land good it does land
good that's amazing
um but i drive that car to the comedy
store it's my if i want to do like
if i'm really working on something or i
really want to be jazzed up for a set
i'll take that car to the comedy store
because it's so loud and [ __ ] smoky
and
everything's like your whole body you
feel it you like
you're excited when you get there it's
like you're on a stimulant
yeah i know it's it's uh it's fun man
like all of that stuff um look at these
guys
you know since the last time i did this
this show i got to
finally fly uh an a-star which was uh
what the cops and the
news guys fly and that was that was the
coolest thing a-star helicopter we
should tell people
is is the coolest thing i've ever flown
as far as like
um just the power it had compared to
what i you know i fly these little
[ __ ] egg beaters or whatever but like
i did until all that [ __ ] happened
um
but uh i got one of the last flights i
did
i got to fly a buddy of mine who was
training me to get my instrument like i
passed the test
um and then after you passed the test
you have two years so i still have two
years i have to december of next year
to pass it so i gotta finish that part
of it
you know did we do a podcast since you
took me up
have you done one since you took me up i
think we did i think we did yeah
did we jamie yeah [ __ ] that was fun we
went over downtown la and you realize
how many of those buildings have
helicopter spots on the top yeah
that was fun man it's just it's crazy to
me
that with a helicopter you could just
kind of go wherever you want to go yeah
just [ __ ] float around
just go wherever you can just stop it
it's but
but then what it is is you give up speed
yeah
for that design you give there's all
kinds of dragon just the way it's
designed
for what that you want to do with it you
give up speed so i get
envious of planes or even if you get
like a cessna like they can just fly
though i mean i think even like the
some of the smaller ones can fly faster
than the some of the faster hell i mean
you have to have like 8 million
helicopter maybe that could fly faster
but anything that i've [ __ ] with
you can't come anywhere near like most
of them 120 130 knots and then it
depends on
head wind or tail not to a mile an hour
well it's it's like
it depends on how uh the wind because
you can literally be flying 90 knots
and have like a [ __ ] 50 that would
not not what i fly but a significant
headwind
um this is all [ __ ] you have to know on
the test and the second you you take the
test you [ __ ]
i forget but um you'll actually be going
slower
i've had times like especially out like
in like palm desert and stuff where
there's like a venturi with the way the
mountains are and when the [ __ ]
the wind comes in which can be really
[ __ ] scary um as far as how it throws
you around you're looking down at the
highway
with what i fly and they're going faster
than you and you're just sitting like
and then that's when it sucks because
also with a helicopter
you you the whole you can't just like
take your hands off of [ __ ]
so you have to you you're literally it's
like your porsche like you're
you know i imagine like uh trying to
parallel park that car even though it's
a lighter car it's a nightmare
i have a 68 ford f-100 when i first had
it i didn't have power steering dude and
it was just like
i mean i remember when you brought that
thing to the ice house that thing is the
[ __ ]
yeah i love that old truck that's kind
of my thing
i like the trucks and then i like uh
old like not pimp cars
like the guy who he's a pimp but he's
not a pimp
like like you know what i mean like not
literally a pimp he doesn't have a
stable of [ __ ] but he's crushing life
like i like that car like uh like if i
was going to get another car i would get
a 67
cadillac eldorado and it's actually the
color that i loved
that was in that the tarantino movie but
somebody was selling one
and i sort of got it by the time i saw
the youtube video was already sold i
would have bought that [ __ ] car
it's the most gangster man's car
like just the the back end of that car
it's it's perfection i absolutely
love that [ __ ] car that's a beautiful
car 67 el dorado
would you get a convertible or a regular
no i hate convertibles do you really all
convertibles
uh yeah i kind of i got i'm a little
sexist with the convertible
there's one convertible that i like the
one that i have the 65 corvette
there no that's not that that's a 70. no
no that's that's uh
what year is that it's it's the car that
the the woman playing uh
margot what's the name margot robbie
there it is there it is there it is
right there that looks like it's green
there but i think it was uh
blue not that one no not that one over
uh they got the suspenders right to the
left of that
yeah that one there that car oh wow you
got to see the back end of that car
that um that's the late the 67 or 68 or
something like that but the back end
look up 67 cadillac el dorado rear end
this is what i do while you're learning
how to train a [ __ ]
bear to ride a bicycle i look at this
[ __ ]
oh wow click on that first one click on
the first one you can see a little bit
of the side of the car i mean look at
that that's beautiful
that is beautiful you need one of those
in your life bill i do i need you
driving one of those this is what i love
about my wife
as i'll show her that what do you think
about that she's like that's a [ __ ]
good looking car and
she would be cool if i got something
like that i think for sure
yeah but look at that color i'm too
fair-skinned to drive that
you need olive skin no no more you could
pull it off you could pull it off you
need one of them paperboy hats
though now that that thing would that
thing would [ __ ]
that thing would blend too much in with
my beard
i just look like it'd be the ginger
mobile what color would you get
there uh there's a year they got there's
a there's a blue that they have
um it's not that blue it's more
it's more of a oh look at that red one
click on that red one in the middle
but look at the front end of that when
your lights are flipped out look at that
thing my god look how good that looks in
red
that's a [ __ ] beautiful car
oh but the lines in that car that's just
like and then that's the kind of come
you're not going to smoke a cigar
driving on the street riding that
[ __ ] you have to
yeah that's beautiful i think i'm gonna
get one
get one i know boy am i gonna put it
then i'm gonna be that guy with the
[ __ ] garage put it here
you can park it here i'll give you a key
i got plenty right hey
all right dude this is why you're the
number one podcast in the world i'm
trying to help people
i'm trying to encourage uh irresponsible
behavior and if you continue to own your
podcast you can buy something like that
and if you don't
your [ __ ] agent will buy that
yeah i love them i love cadillac
convertibles too though
i don't like um muscle car convertibles
after certainly like mine uh
that corvette that i have out there
you've seen that silver one yeah i love
that in a convertible
but that has a aftermarket suspension an
aftermarket frame
i've seen i've seen none of those cars
the fact that the old ones
those frame it's two there's too much
bounce there's too much shake and wiggle
you have to have like a an aftermarket
chassis it's far stiffer
they make it so that it's like very very
rigid it doesn't bounce around nearly as
much yeah then they used to make like a
sway bar or something that you would put
in there because i know in my truck when
i take a turn i have to grab
underneath the seat and hang on so i
don't slide into the door
they can upgrade your coilovers and
stuff like that and
put a better suspension i have a nice
balance
of a little bit of modern on it and
still fighting it so you feel like
because it still shifts on the column
which i think is badass
but then when i get on the highway i got
to stay in the right lane you know three
on the tree right
yeah do you have disc brakes on it do
you swap disc brakes out i had uh
it it had it had just the shoes on it
and then drums
the drum brakes yeah and then i uh
converted those
chris fatis helped me with those and
um then what did i do after that
i switched out the radiator because they
tended to run hot so they put an
aluminum one in
and um what else did we do to it
tight power brakes and then uh power
steering
titus used to have a sweet i think it
was a 55
chevy that they made for him on the show
rides
it was incredible oh that chip foose car
right yeah i think chip foose made it
yeah
it was incredible though just i don't
know if he still has it he might have
lost it when he got divorced and all
that jazz
but it was no i think he got it back did
he i think he got it back but i i i like
those
christopher titus i like those uh those
resto mod
cars is sort of the perfect it is there
it is look at that [ __ ] thing
yeah that's pretty well that is a work
of art
god it's weird that's it's all very
modified too 56
bel air custom for by chip foose
go down jamie and that one on the left
hand right there with titus right there
i think that's him
yeah look at that [ __ ] i mean that's a
badass car
[ __ ] that is incredible
that car is incredible like when do you
like
look at that or drive that and not smile
yeah
that's what i i i i don't know i i like
also
i i'm into those cab over engine [ __ ]
trucks i like weird
it's a cab over engine what is that look
those up those are those were the trucks
uh 40s and 50s and the reason why they
had that was there was some weird law
where they didn't want trucks to get too
long so then that affected the
so they kept the tractor trailer long
and then they they put the engine
cab over engine is what it stands for so
the engine's below you while you're
sitting there
yeah so if you look at some of the ones
that people have fixed up
they're [ __ ] wild that is wild look
at that thing
yeah wow but the thing is if you do a
gig in like wyoming you can find an all
original one just like sitting in like
junkyards and [ __ ]
look at that [ __ ] thing god damn
that's beautiful like i always was like
one of those car shows like fast and
loud the ones that i've watched
throughout the years i always wish that
somebody would do one of those i had
that guy on the podcast he was awesome
yeah he brought his own tequila oh
there's another great one from when i
was a kid
that yellow one uh down that's a ford
yup i love those because that was like
the fire engines looked like that thing
but it's like what would you do with it
but drive around take it to the store
it's for sale gateway classic cars i
know but that's
that's like the dumb [ __ ] i like those i
like those kind of
the gmc uh rv from stripes
and and you got to do it in the palm
desert [ __ ]
the the the ron burgundy green
you like very odd cars yeah well at
first i think you you're into mustangs
and you're into [ __ ]
like the gto's and the ones you're
supposed to like yeah and then i'll
ignore what you just did there
um and then i mean look at that you got
to get the interior on that [ __ ]
thing
it's a scooby-doo mobile that's the
mystery mobile no they had a van
okay click on click on the one uh you're
on the right the lower left
all the way to the lower left uh uh from
the cluster on the right
yeah click on that [ __ ] thing no
that's not it
yeah see it which one you want
it's the one it's the best green one
they have just click there it is
look at that and inside it looks like a
ron burgundy suit like it's the green
plaid type [ __ ]
get a little humidor in there drive
around do some [ __ ] look at that i
mean look at that come on man that's the
[ __ ]
[ __ ] so you like those old cars like
gtos and i like all of those but like
what i don't like about them
is the baby boomers like them and they
have a zillion dollars so then all of a
sudden it's like you know
this is a mustang shelby we're gonna
start the midnight 250 000
it's like oh [ __ ] yourself so
i like uh you know i like a 65 ford
galaxy that's what frank murphy season 4
episode family that's what he drives
uh i like station wagons have you ever
seen those icon thrift masters do you
know what that is
um jonathan ward the guy from icon he
takes uh
an old thrift master and uh re-does it
completely from the bottom up it's the
[ __ ] most incredible car
it drives like a car but look at that it
looks insane
look at that thing they and they they do
it from the bottom up so it's all like
modern brakes modern suspension
beautiful and that's what i love but
then when you go in inside i want it to
look like the year that that truck was
look at that silver one
the one that right above your cursor
yeah look at that [ __ ] hey
i've seen actually i looked at one i
accidentally came upon that one god
that's beautiful i got another one it's
a weird one
look up gmc uh i always figure out the
name of these things were a
parade of progress that's what it's
called
i think uh that's they would drive these
things like elephants into town they
were like a living room
giant like truck slash rv thing what the
[ __ ] are these
there things called yeah right that
thing look at that [ __ ] thing
what the [ __ ] how do you even know about
this so
so the great thing is you open the door
and there's like a spiral staircase
where you
you go up and in there what they usually
had was back in the day because they
would open it up on the side they would
they would drive them in like elephants
and make like a semi-circle and people
would walk in
what is that i don't know what i don't
know what they have in there
that's a yeah that's an airplane engine
or something why is there an airplane
engine in the middle of that
i don't know because somebody oh they
customized it power for the air age i
think they were
it was this weird sort of uh after world
war two see there they are they're black
and white they are like driving it in
driving them into town and look at the
steering wheel you were right in the
center and there was like a little
spiral staircase that you walked up
because those things go for like i i
forget how much like two three million
bucks or something oh that's 1936 it
says parade of progress so it shows you
what it is look at that [ __ ]
yeah that's just weird [ __ ] that's so
that that's what you want one of those
a rolling podcast studio no that [ __ ] is
too weird but i
i appreciate it like when you know that
old bmw
where the the whole front of the car
opens up and you got it the steering
wheel like goes out like disconnects and
goes out with the front
and then that one all right i just it
would help if i knew the names of the
cars
the steering wheel disconnects
had it and family matters that's what i
know about it that's it yeah
that's look at this so how you get in is
you you like
open the front oh yeah click on the red
one there it is yeah
saying there's a steering wheel oh does
it disconnect there's something weird no
it seems like the steering wheel stays
it looks like it disconnects well maybe
like it adjusts
and comes back you enter through the so
if you get in a front
end collision you got to kick the
windows out to get out of the car yeah
and it's three wheels too
there's one urkel i forgot about urkel
see his well his came off from the car i
met him one time he's like the coolest
[ __ ] guy i heard he's really nice
i guess it bends over there you see how
it's turned down to the side
oh it bends and then you step over it
whoa yeah i knew there was something
there was something about the steering
wheel yeah there's a lot of weird [ __ ]
out there but you like weird stuff
you're not necessarily like you you you
know what this is listening to cool
things
no it's like if you get into music if
you really get into a band
like if you're into ac dc right can you
really listen to you shook me all night
long again
okay you're like no dude you got to
listen to what's next to the moon get it
hot some of that
you know or like uh c-o-d like i like
after a while you just like all right
you know like i would say shook me all
night long is the mustang gt
of ac dc songs and it's just like if
you're out here there's a zillion
mustangs but it's like
you after a while you want you want to
see you know it's part of human beings
you want something
a little bit different it's a little
different it's cooler like i kind of
learned from fast and loud that the um
was it the ford falcon or something had
the same chassis as the [ __ ] mustang
but like it's just a way cooler car
because
everybody goes for like the mustang you
i mean you know what you're gonna spend
all that money and then some other
[ __ ] [ __ ] shows up and he has one
too
that doesn't bother me ah bugs me
it's like it's like when you're in a
comedy club and then if even if somebody
just touches on the topic you're like
i can't talk about that yes i get that
because then it becomes like oh they all
do that
i get that but there's a reason why
everybody loves mustangs i love them too
but i have this weird thing where i love
the interior up to 66
but i like the back end on 60 wait 67 68
yeah i like that backhand but i hate but
that's when they got this [ __ ] steering
wheel
like the steering wheel in like in in
the 60s looks like an old-school
steering wheel
and that one that they have in 67 or 68
was when they first came out with that
one
that one starts to look like oh cars are
going to get ugly now quickly
the last muscle car that i like that
that uh that i i
vividly remember like the last year
would probably be the 70 camaro with
like that shark nose front
i like that and then there's a few
there's a buick riviera the boat tail
from the early 70s that i like um
i'm really into those big two-door sedan
sort of like
uh you know he he's his own man
oh yeah i love those cars i [ __ ] love
those cars and um
you know i'm trying to think like
there's a few cars in the 80s
it really tapers off though but i like
ford trucks right up into 86
i didn't like when they did the first
that first design of the aerodynamic
headlights i didn't like but then there
was one in the early 90s
um the one oj had that front end on his
bronco that one is the [ __ ]
yeah i saw one yesterday exactly like
like oj's
like totally re restored i i like muscle
cars up into 71.
71 seems like the last year like 71
barracuda is still a really nice car
then it gets into 72 they start looking
sketchy 73 they look sketchy
the worst thing was they kept they kept
the model name and then it was just
completely de-bald yes
like when your friend starts going out
with just some total [ __ ]
and all of a sudden you can't hang out
anymore like there was that era
you know the mustang two cobras oh yeah
once they got into the 80s with mustangs
they were useless
the set late late 70s early 80s and once
the gas crisis hit
they started making economical mustangs
mustangs that didn't eat so much gas
they were useless it's just a it's a
hard fall
between if you go from 67 to 77 it's
like what the [ __ ] happened to you
then also the mustang got all fat like
the mach 1 and everything it just it was
like
kind of got into its elvish years you
know hey i'm the mustang i'm
resting on my laurels here well there's
no pizzazz to them
you know like late late 70s 79 mustang
there's no pizzazz
this is how bad it went it became so
quickly if you watch like the remember
they had a game show network
i used to love that because i i was in
fascinated with prices
you know and like they would be like uh
like they actually tried to pass off a
chevy vega
as a sports car really and these people
were losing their minds and i remember
the chevy vega
like a lot of like you know guys who
knew [ __ ] about cars back in the day
they would try to like jam corvette
engines into
because they couldn't afford a corvette
so they but they knew about
you know how to build cars and stuff so
they were real light too
yeah there was always somebody had one
of those like an el camino up on blocks
yeah i'm gonna finish that someday man
yeah and
the el camino's a rare breed a person
that wants a pickup truck that's
[ __ ] to chevelle that's really what it
is it's like a chevelle
front end that looks good in the front
and then you get to the back like oh
and then i in the early the 80s look at
that vega
yeah that was considered sporty those
back four girls had butts
um well girls with butts didn't get put
on tv
not funny yeah that's another amazing
thing like how do we
what what what happened when we realized
was it sir mix a lot
like what woke us up yeah he he made the
ass mainstream i'm gonna give him credit
might have been before that who else was
it
it was all about tits yeah white guys
were running [ __ ] and it was about tits
i don't know why it was all about
titties something happened
something happened and it became asses
became
really important because then i think
like yeah because now the fake ass
i think is probably more prevalent than
the fake t like remember by the 90s was
like sort of the apex of the fake titty
you'd watch porn and the tit almost
looked like bloodshot there'd be like
veins on the side like they'd stretch
the skin
you see oh oh yeah that was really bad
that was a really bad yep uh fat bottom
girls before that
but yeah much before it but yeah that
was just a strong i don't think yeah
they didn't he was still freddie mercury
prancing around in the video i think
yeah good song though yeah
what was it like where who was like no
it wasn't jennifer god god bless you yes
because i was always an asthma always i
always just felt like that was the
nucleus of a woman if she had a nice ass
the rest of her body was going to be
nice
i didn't give a [ __ ] again eat cupcakes
he's great they won't be hanging on your
[ __ ] knees when i'm 50.
bald smoking a cigar doing a podcast
it's weird though that the sh like the
shape caught on
it's very strange like the what what's
inju what
what guys are attracted to changed well
i think because
white people were so dominant with
[ __ ]
owning everything that their idea of
beauty became
the standard and just generally speaking
the idea of beauty changed too that's
what's strange
it's like i would say it's somewhere yom
tv raps
somewhere around there just making up
[ __ ]
somewhere around there i'm going to give
ed lover and the other dr
dre credit i think it's it happened
around the same time girls lost their
pubes
because when we were in high school all
everyone had pubes even in college
everyone had pubes the apex of pubes was
the 70s
but you were proud of your pubes in the
70s yeah
dude i remember like you'd go to the
[ __ ] public pool and the chicks had
like the big
there was like [ __ ] coming out the sides
i remember thinking i was a little kid
like oh my god you can see your pubes
oh yeah pubes were now pubes are
disgusting there was
muffs if you're a girl and you got a
full bush now you're a dangerous woman
but then i would say
that that was probably dr j
in the aba crossing over made women
proud of their muffs
what just my job
there's no research we just started
talking just making this up
but there's there is a clear shift that
happened it's just like what happened
what what made that clear shift
porn caused the people to get rid of the
pubes that's definitely what happened
because porn led the way they they
trimmed the pubes first and then
everybody trimmed the pubes and it went
too far
yeah now no one has cubes no then it
went too far yeah too far yeah
like a little bush yeah i would like
yeah you should look like a woman
yeah yeah not like a cancer patient
yeah yeah so
listen if you're banging me i'm just
happy happy you showed up
god bless you take it on for the team
you can find beauty in everything
but when i was a kid i mean everyone had
pubes
it was a thing it is a that's a weird
weird moment in our our culture that we
all just decided pubes are disgusting
i think more that they need to be
maintained yes
if there's going to be a camera an
eighth of an inch from it
and then
gynecological yeah so
so what's this movie did uh it did this
movie's called the king of staten island
uh judd apatow pete davidson
look at your mustache oh yeah oh you
need one of those in your life
why don't you grow one of those ah keep
it
it was really annoying to eat with cause
club soda kenny told me
because he was the guy i was saying am i
doing this this right here because
there's a whole way to grow it where
it's like
he goes all right he goes if you're
gonna do the cop fireman one he goes the
hair has to go over the
over your top lip and kenny had all
these great old
id's from when he was a cop and
um what is this movie about
it's uh it's sort of autobiographical
um of pete davidson's life where he's
playing a kid whose dad is a firefighter
who died in a fire it's not 911 like
pete's real dad
um and it's basically his mom
hasn't dated they just sort of froze
which i you know i think is something
that kind of happened
in his family and then all of a sudden
his mother started dating and it was
weird for him
so basically uh his mother
you know through whatever circumstances
are on a ruin and i end up meeting her
after me and pete you know his character
i don't like his
and i'm coming to his house to [ __ ]
yell or whatever and then i see
his his mom played by marissa tomei and
then all of a sudden
you know you know we click or whatever
we start dating whatever and then he
[ __ ] hates it and the comedy
ensues but it's you know it's got a lot
of heart you know it's not 100
comedy but um yeah marissa tomei
uh dom lombardosi uh
steve no it's streaming everywhere
except netflix it's uh
it's going to be like it's like that
movie that kid movie trolls whatever
they did is what
universal is doing with this one where
it's going to be anywhere where you can
stream movies so it was supposed to be
in the movie theater
it was going to be a movie theater and
then all this stuff happened so then
uh people who make movies are deciding
uh we're going to hold on to some of
this stuff which you're doing with some
movies
this thing fortunately they're going to
put out there it is apple tv verizon
youtube google play amazon prime
basically
why wouldn't netflix hop on board with
this come on netflix
um i don't think there's a it's a come
on netflix thing i think eventually
you'll probably end up there but i think
first they do this this is the way
they're gonna get their box office
i guess you get it on microsoft how many
people are buying movies on microsoft
it's like you'd be surprised i would be
that's why i'm asking there would be
i would think
[Laughter]
that's such an easy answer you'd be
surprised that's like a po
that was like a political answer i i had
no answer for you sorry
many people are buying it on microsoft
um yeah so do you think this is a good
thing
that movies are being forced to stream i
kind of like it
i mean i don't want movie theaters to go
under but i do like the option of being
able to watch
a newly released movie at home yeah i
think everything's going to adapt but i
don't think the movie theater's ever
going to go away because i i
still enjoy going to the movies it's
also it's a way to get out of the house
you get a sitter
you reconnect with your wife that's
right we're friends popcorn this is fun
all of a sudden your jokes come back
right you're having fun anytime i hang
with my wife
like if if we get like a couple days
away
it the magic instant oh yeah instant
comes back and then when we get back to
the
house it's like the grind again and we
just start laughing
like we gotta remember we gotta remember
those two days so the key is to have
those two day little things
enough that you don't forget it so you
don't start [ __ ] growing apart do you
guys do date nights
yeah yeah i had date nights with my wife
and we were doing them when i was
when i was at the store all the time
when comedy was up i was doing them on
saturday night
because she didn't have to get up early
in the morning for the kids to take the
kids to school so she could be
rested and refreshed didn't have to go
to school the next day
so didn't have to get up on sunday so it
was a it was a good day so i just would
take sunday off a stand-up
yeah we do date nights and this is the
thing as much as women seem impossible
to guys especially someone like me
with all my [ __ ] issues it's like
just something like that
does wonders yeah for your
your connection and um then we also had
like once a week we were doing like
uh before we got pregnant again we were
doing uh a family dinner
and that was the best and what we were
going to was a bunch of like
uh just mom-and-pop places in like the
valley and
out in pasadena and stuff like that of
these places that are just
you know legendary in you know in that
area but they don't have a chain
so it's cool because you feel like
you're giving you know regular people
money and business and we would go there
and when like
that was a big thing when i was growing
up before you had all these screens and
all of this [ __ ]
going out to dinner with your family
yeah i remember being excited they used
to have this chain in
massachusetts remember pewter pot yeah
they basically they made muffins somehow
they were a chain
that made muffins and then they expanded
into having full dinners
and everything was made out of wood it
was very like uh 70s and that was like a
big thing
my dad came i was going to pewter pot
tonight and you're like sight
and i would always get whatever like
cheeseburger and fries and then a
blueberry muffin
such a weird order but i was a kid and
you wouldn't get fat it was [ __ ]
awesome so
i want my kids to have a little bit of
that
that sort of um i don't know i'm
probably romancing it but i think it's
it's
because it was from my childhood but i
think it's an important thing to do [ __ ]
like that yeah i'm a big fan of mom and
pop restaurants there's a place we used
to go to in
woodland hills called brandywine and the
owner uh peggy and chris the owners
there was
the owners one the female owner was the
chef
and the male owner was the maitre d and
they were a married couple they'd been
together forever
and they when when we met them they were
probably i want to say
in their 70s like pretty deep in their
server there was they were already fair
fairly along pretty far down the road
and then
they eventually sold the place they sold
the place when it was sad
you know and then some new people bought
it but i think it went under now but uh
oh it was a great little place a small
place it didn't see very much did i get
over that sadness
i get old cause that [ __ ] really used to
depress me what i look at was like you
know
when they opened this restaurant and
they were young there was old people
that were upset about whatever they
cleared out
and it just happens you know what i mean
like well i was just upset
that i couldn't see them you know i just
enjoyed their company it was it was
always
you know we had been going there for 10
years so it was one of those places what
i do is i take the humanity out of it
joe
it's a cycle of life it's just like the
praying mantis and the lizard i know
dude i tell you this [ __ ]
this [ __ ] uh
this whole quarantine thing really i
like
i never realized what a [ __ ] idiot i
am yeah you're telling me i said
you were does everything i'm doing why
the [ __ ] did i just do this why did this
need
to [ __ ] be on here you won why joe no
big deal
you're a clean freak or something look
at me i'm i'm cutting up his ashes like
it's coke
now that takes me back to chelsea going
around the apex
i have a cocaine memory from uh i never
did coke but uh
of this lady doing it i was coming home
from kelly's roast beef
joe coke wow that's what i'm saying
i'm smart enough to realize it's not for
me what about me yeah we were dry
i fi i can snap on weed
[Laughter]
i don't need to be doing coke weed in an
espresso
you're ready to fight we're uh driving
back from kelly's roast beef do you
remember kelly's recipe from revere yeah
great you know what's so funny i don't
think i ever went there
really i drove by it a million times
always going by cappy's liquors on the
way up to the calories
beef was great remember caffeine's
liquor yeah i do yeah near
kowloon yeah you drive up yeah kelly's
beef had clams too didn't they have
clams those fried clams
i always that was one of those places i
meant to get to i always meant to get to
that and then that steakhouse with the
giant cactus
i was like yeah i'm going to try it i'm
going to place what the [ __ ] was that
hilltop
yes and i was going to eat there someday
i always ask my
i just love the cows the fake cows out
front and we were living on the north
shore then so we would drive my dad into
work and we would always go down
uh route one and we would go buy that
and i would think like you know and
there was
also a hockey rink up there that had a
bruins emblem that they were allowed to
use before like all the
um the corporate people really like you
can't use our logo so that bruins
thing and i was convinced that's where
the bruins practiced
i went to hilltop steakhouse once and it
was
for some reason i have it connected in
my mind with a boxing mask that was on
tv
because i was so bummed out uh sugar ray
leonard
fought terry norris and uh that was that
name i should say
terry norris was a monster and so so was
sugar ray when he was in his prime but
he got older and he fought terry norris
when terry norris was a [ __ ]
just a demon he was so good and sugar
ray just should had no business fighting
him and i remember
eating food just being bummed out just
just thinking [ __ ] is this just what
happens to all these guys
like like they all decide they all
decide one more fight
one more fight let me let me do it and
he came back and beat a few see if we
can find that
could you imagine if your body broke
down in around 35 you couldn't do stand
anymore you definitely try to go for one
more set yeah but it's different
it's different it is i thought it was
the same you're right it's different
terry norris totally different was in
his prime and he was just so
fast and elite and sugar ray was just i
want to say he was like 38 or something
like that
i don't know how old he was but it was
it was hard to watch
from madison square garden in new york
when i think of sugar ray leonard i
don't think i mean what what about that
division he was in oh my god
hearns duran and leonard i mean
well he fought hagler long you know i
mean he came back and fought hagler and
then
hagler retired after that one loss he
just like i'm good
but it was just watching terry norris
yeah he went to italy and started making
movies
yeah hilarious movies i got a buddy of
mine that is convinced that fight was
fixed
by the italian mob and then his payoff
was the game of movie career in italy
it might be true your buddy might be
right
there's something about it that i've
watched i'm like man it almost looks
like haggar's taking something off of
his punches
and i also i just don't see him doing
that i don't think he's i don't
see him ever doing that that's why but i
also didn't see him retiring
i think he might have gotten [ __ ] on a
decision
on that fight because if i could i
really felt could have i was such a
hearns
i mean hagler fan and i also what about
what about tommy hearns
being as tall as he was but could make
that weight
um when he fought sugar ray i think he
was only 22
and he was uh 147 and sugar ray stopped
him
after angelo dundee gave him that that
speech in the corner
you're blowing it kid remember that i'll
never forget that i
you know the one i remember one of the
greatest ones i saw a corner guy
was that uh corrales castillo fight
oh and when he gets in the corner and
he'd been knocked down
uh for like i don't know how many times
kept spitting out his mouthpiece and
they took away a point or something he
gets
he goes into his corner and i remember
his is
his manager whatever you call a guy he's
in the corner he goes training he goes
you better [ __ ] get inside now
i don't even know what that means i
forget he said that and then this
[ __ ] guy
charlie murphy rest his soul told me
about that fight he's like bill you got
to see this fight he goes i woke up my
whole family
it was a wild ass fight and he actually
charlie he was such a funny guy man
he hurt his foot that's how much he was
into it
like when he came back after getting
knocked down and then knocked out the
other guy i always forget crowless
castillo uh was uh
corrales is is the guy who won that
fight right well they fought more than
once
i believe um diego corrales
yeah he's the guy and he died on a
motorcycle exactly right that's what i
was gonna say
yeah terrible yeah i'll take an
underrated fight when i back just back
when i had time i used to watch this
[ __ ]
was uh evander holyfield versus michael
doakes
oh you remember that fight that was a
great that was a great fight holyfield
had so many great fights
what do you think he was a that guy was
a warrior he is yeah
he's coming back do you know that i want
to see that he's training
mike mike tyson's training they're both
training
in their 50s yeah here it is michael
dokes
yeah it was i mean it's just amazing how
much longevity
holyfield had and holyfield started as a
cruiserweight i remember when he beat
dwight muhammad kawi for the
cruiserweight title
and then uh gained all this weight to go
up
i mean when he was a cruiserweight in
the 80s when i was lifting and i was
young and all that [ __ ] i was like
that's
that's the body i want that's what i'm
going for of course i couldn't get it
but
i was like that's the shape i want to be
give me how stupid i look if i [ __ ]
look like that
oh you look amazing going on stage
telling jokes just wear something that
covers it up a little bit
what a poncho
[Music]
oh my god this is round two look at the
people standing up i mean this [ __ ] was
just
they're just oh no watch stokes oh
right hand that's it they stop it that
was interesting
richard steele was the same guy that
stopped julio cesar chavez and meldrick
taylor with like
two seconds left to go in the final
round
when meldrick taylor was up
on the fight and julio cesar chavez
dropped him meldrick taylor got up
and richard c was like are you are you
ready to go on dude he has more muscle
in his
trapezius whatever the [ __ ] that's
called traps i have in my whole [ __ ]
body
he's a specimen holyfield was a specimen
what's interesting about holyfield too
he was like the first guy that ever
really
put weight on successfully like he had
this uh this crazy strength and
conditioning program
that he did to go up to heavyweight
where you know he was
fairly thin when he was a cruiserweight
and started lifting weights and lifting
weights back then
most people thought lifting weights was
terrible for you there was a lot that
was a big thing in basketball don't lift
weights it's going to [ __ ] up your shot
they thought you were going to like
send the ball past them well you know
what it is it's from being stiff and
sore
when you're stiff and sore it does [ __ ]
you up it's
it [ __ ] you up with boxing it [ __ ] you
about everything but it's a matter of
doing it correctly so that your
your body recovers enough so that when
you actually fight you're not stiff and
sore but you have all that extra muscle
so this is great by the way
cars fights cigars praying mantis men's
stuff come on
yes i love it right yeah
yeah though that that era of boxing man
those are the the
the golden era when we were kids my god
you know abc why world of sports
get up and watch the fights yeah i
remember watching the leon spinks
uh muhammad ali they showed it on tv
must have been a replay
i remember watching that and just kept
thinking muhammad ali was going to come
back
it was the one that he lost yeah uh
against leon spinks
i also remember the the the uh mike
tyson
uh michael spinks fight and i remember
the pizza didn't even get there and i
remember my buddy was all excited dude
my dad ordered the fight and they had
just finished their basement
and we went downstairs and we were
sitting there to watch it it was over in
like 90 seconds yeah and i just remember
my buddy
he got off the couch and he was on all
fours like an inch from the tv
just screaming what the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ]
because we didn't understand there
wasn't the education mainstream
education of what a body blow did to you
so unless somebody got hit in the head
and then their mouthpiece went flying we
didn't understand because that last shot
he
was a hook to the body and you didn't
understand like literally their internal
organs just slammed to the other side of
that rib cage he didn't understand that
that was happening here it is here's the
whole fight
yeah this was an amazing amazing moment
because
spinx was another guy who went up from
light heavyweight beat larry holmes
and then became the heavyweight champion
then was fighting tyson but yeah we were
yelling at spanx jinx cause we just
wanted we were rooting for tights but we
wanted to see a fight
spanx had a good right hand but he just
you could see he's he's
paralyzed here i mean he's fighting a
guy that's just so much bigger than him
and he's getting smashed
mike tyson was just such a force in
nature at the time yeah
sphinx just really had no business
fighting legitimate heavyweights he
fought larry holmes and larry was past
his prime
and you know he beat larry by decision
but oh i thought he beat him bad i
thought like that was like oh no you
know what i'm thinking of was was
the time holmes fought ali yes and he
was looking over at the ref like what
the [ __ ] are you going to stop this that
was bad
people to that to the end of larry
holm's career didn't appreciate him
because that they they loved ali so much
so you heard him with his right hand
here
and then he's swarming on him
i remember seeing this video of muhammad
ali promoting
here it is right here boom body shot
he goes down spins gets up
referee gives him an eight count he says
i'm fine
oh i thought he went down on that one
that was no that was a body shot and
then he gets hit with a right hand right
here tyson steps
bang there it is oh that was oh flat i
see i forgot about that
yeah he's just like [ __ ] this man
[ __ ] his body's like [ __ ] this dude do
you realize the [ __ ] balls it takes
to [ __ ] walk
oh you do you did it jesus christ
i mean those guys you walk into an arena
shirtless scary that's [ __ ] amazing
what's really scary is it's like you
think about it for weeks and weeks up to
it and obviously i never did it at this
level
but at that level when the whole world
is watching and you know that this is a
just an enormous moment and you just got
waylaid by one of the greatest
heavyweights of all time and flattened
that was crazy you know i was watching
about uh
he was so fun to watch because he
annoyed so many people because he was so
cocky
and he had such a weird style is that
that prince uh
oh my god is that guy fun to watch oh he
was amazing you know tyson had syphilis
in that or not something like that in
that fight no that was uh
buster douglas did he yeah he liked the
clap or something i think it was this
right thing was the fight he won
yeah the f when he fought buster douglas
he just didn't train
very hard for it just really was just
dominating everybody and
just took it for granted and busted he
still almost won
still drop buster and to this day like
if you watch that fight when buster's
down
it's more than 10 seconds yeah but the
thing was he didn't go to the corner
fast enough i thought
mm-hmm and he picked up the count i
thought he would have got up i don't
know
i remember where i was when i watched
that i remember all of that [ __ ] i was
at my buddy mitch's house
we were upstairs and was on his [ __ ]
square tv
and i was like you know cause you cheer
for the underdog
and he was all bummed out going i want
to see mike lose and i was just like
i didn't realize what i had lost
as a sports fan because you're losing
greatness
not like he's not great but you know
what i mean you wanted to see that
undefeated
right keep going thing and then
afterwards you know it's a weird thing
but the buster douglas in that fight you
know the whole story behind it his mom
died yeah and he was devastated
and so he was always a really really
talented guy that just didn't work hard
enough
but that fight he trained like a
[ __ ] he trained like a real
champion
probably because he came out yeah didn't
want to face didn't want to think about
it they probably just focused on
he was that maybe also he was like doing
it he was dedicating it to his mom
but he once again the human element that
i just removed
[Laughter]
i am a i am i am is this what you're
finding out from this the
the pandemic being locked up and having
too much alone time
like that yeah i understand i understand
my anger now i don't know how to fix it
but i
understand what is it what is your anger
it's
feeling like i'm not gonna be heard and
things are going to go in a way i don't
want them to be so the second there's a
there's a suggestion different than mine
i catastrophize in my head
and i don't will be like well you know
what actually i can't do that because
i'm doing joe's podcast
maybe i could do that tomorrow i just
hear the information and feel like i
have no power and then i go oh what the
[ __ ]
and then my wife's like i just asked a
question and then
i am so [ __ ] up here i have to like
it takes it only takes me like two
minutes and then i come in
i put my head to the side of her head
and i just go i'm sorry
i don't tell you you married a fuck-up
you blew it you're not gonna you're not
good at reading people
you have no one to blame but yourself
like that i apologize like an [ __ ]
no my i and that's another thing there's
another thing too is i've
i also in this have never loved my wife
more
you know gave me a son and it's just
like it's one of those things where
you know you just said that's a
beautiful really sit there going like
i am really like i am way way more of a
[ __ ] [ __ ] than i thought i was i
knew i was but i didn't think i was that
bad
so you realize you've got issues but you
don't know how to solve them that's what
it is
i i realized that i had issues that i
thought i was past
[Music]
that's what [ __ ] me up but you feel
like
like all right so i've taken care of
that now i can focus on this and it's
like no no this is still in this pile
you thought it was six feet high it's 12
feet high and it's it was
uh um
yeah it was demoralizing so don't you
think no one is part of the
way to fix it though yeah but then you
have to go through the torture of it
of cause it's not like it's not like you
know like the dr phil episode
you need to understand you know [ __ ]
yellow people whatever the [ __ ] you
oh okay thanks phil
and like you're just going to go do that
it's it's like
then you have to do the [ __ ] work and
it's so easy to just go back into your
your yes it's a deep groove worn into
your
personality and you're trying to get out
of the rut and it's just easy to go back
into it and just be on autopilot
that's why people autopilot that's why
people like psychedelics
because it separates you so much from
who you are you get a chance to look at
yourself
it's one of the things that that comes
out of it i should have done that when i
was younger
can't do it now like right now on this
podcast i don't
do it i don't think a little bit
professional i'm supposed to be
promoting one of these feature films
we've already done it we've promoted it
looks great i'm excited i'm excited to
see you with a mustache
oh so you're saying i'm done and then i
can now do this
you could do a little drugs just a
little mushrooms
be good for you listen joe i know you're
an influencer but you ain't gonna win on
this one influencer
i will be uh kids get out of the house
and they're [ __ ]
great people hopefully if i did the job
then then
so when they're 18 okay we'll go when
they're 18 i'm going to take you
somewhere
all right when i'm 70 and you're 71.
yeah we'll get blasted together on
mushrooms yeah i'll finally get that
cattle
the pacific northwest which will be
burnt to the ground once they
the the looters take over those six
blocks they're eventually gonna expand
to 12. there'll be no more seattle
the trees will regrow seattle don't say
that how great you ever played the moore
theater love it there it's great
i love seattle i love seattle i'm a big
fan i used to love that uh bellevue
place
the the pool hall that was a it was a
pool hall
connected to a comedy club remember that
did you ever do that place
went under went under real recently it
was [ __ ] great
trying to remember the name of the place
but it was in bellevue
and uh i first went there with callan
calendar was one and told me about i was
like this is
this is my dream a pool hall connected
to a comedy club this is the greatest
thing i've ever heard of
i love that guy he's one of the fastest
minds
that's unbelievable how [ __ ] funny
that guy is it's very funny dude
there it is the parlor yeah permanently
closed
talented guy too i saw him one time with
the bow and arrow
just talking all of this [ __ ] and
somebody hit a he hit a
bullseye and then he did the next one he
split his [ __ ] arrow
talking [ __ ] the whole [ __ ] yes where
did you do this
at this guy's house that had one of
those things and dead luck
brian is a terrible archery there's no
jack [ __ ] about archery hey listen
i know what i saw were you streaming no
i saw this
he talked [ __ ] the whole time and he did
it it was [ __ ] great it was like i
was watching a movie
i bought him a bow listen i gotta tell
you something i think you need to move
him a little bit higher up in your brain
he's one of my best friends that's how
you talk about a friend
i love him i bought him a bow i bought
him a hoyt
carbon spider really nice bow never used
it once
he goes wait i gotta use that bow i got
to use that bow one day i'm like
get off he's probably doing [ __ ] he's
probably standing on the string doing
curls knowing him
maybe he boxes he likes to go to the
boxing gym
likes to mix it up he goes in there and
spars i'm like brian
you're gonna get brain damage you're 53
years old you can't be getting punched
in the face
yeah but he's like a jason statham 53.
[Music]
[Laughter]
because you gotta you have to know that
dude now that we're these old [ __ ]
okay we're hanging in there because you
see people i see at this point
i remember that's when i first felt old
was when i would meet people after shows
and be like oh this guy's got at least
five years on me and i find out they
were five years younger than me
like i'd be like 33 i'd be looking
you're [ __ ] 28 and he was like a real
28 married three kids
and i saw what that looked like you know
uh you know you know this [ __ ]
business this business you get [ __ ] on
like
like i love the harassing to a point on
uh on social media harassing the you
know hey
uh you know hey billy boo's face say
billy fat tits and all that [ __ ] like
that motivates me like that i look you
gotta honestly look at yourself like
they're right yeah they're hanging a
little bit
i need to do some push-ups they will
[ __ ]
bully you into getting in [ __ ] it's all
how you process the information
no yeah there's something to that yeah
this look you talking about fat shaming
i'm telling you that if i wasn't in this
business i would be a fat [ __ ]
i'd get those blonde oreo cookies root
beer floats
i would be [ __ ] hammering that [ __ ]
so be in the business and then yeah
cause then on twitter i would just have
the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] picture just the egg one you
know when nobody knows who you are and i
could be a fat
[ __ ] being like you know just giving
people [ __ ] you got a little fatter
since the last movie i would have a
blast doing that
how's your shoulder it's great it's
better because i've been
uh i finally that was another thing
is this like the shoulder thing also
caused me that i had to slow down
and like the patience you need
to rehab it like you're sitting there
with like at first it's just
the weight of your arm doing the crawls
up the wall then you lay on your side
then it's just the weight of your arm
and then a tuna can then i went into a
can of clams
and now i'm up to the pink weight the
one pounder
and then this is the big this is the big
tipping point when you go from one pound
to two pound
as ridiculous as that sound you're
increasing the weight load by a hundred
percent
and that's when you get hurt because you
want to get like i used to be able to do
like 15 pound
you know 20 pound 25 the those those
sets you used to do yeah
and now i if i you know when it's really
hurting i'd reach for some salt i'm like
it resets it so what i do is i just get
slowly work my way up to three sets of
20
and then when i go to two pounds when i
do it i'll just do three sets of three
so i'm way beneath the weight load that
i did and then you gradually
it requires all of this patience that i
don't [ __ ] have
what is wrong with it um this one i had
a bursitis this one i actually
i i [ __ ] up something else and this
one is totally fine now
but i'm not using it as much because i'm
not using this one so i i do the rehab
on both sides just to keep them
equal i've been doing a lot of core work
a lot of back [ __ ] that i never did
which is how my shoulder got [ __ ] up
because i just did the 80s things you
know this did everything up here
right what i could see i worked on so
all back here
was like we can't [ __ ] hold this [ __ ]
so everything my my shoulders bowed in
and one was higher than the other
and then eventually it just got pinched
yeah
yeah just do these [ __ ] things i know
that's for this but i didn't do anything
for your shoulders too
for the middle of my back or lower back
all of this [ __ ] i don't know what the
[ __ ] i'm talking you ever use bands
yeah bands are a good way to not get
hurt i'm a big fan there's a
product called uh crossover symmetry
it's a series of uh different weight
band i'll show it to you out here i have
it
attached to one of the bars one of the
cages
and these uh these bands they come in
15 pounds 25 pounds 40 pounds bunch of
different weights
you take these things and i do a whole
series of exercises with my shoulders
it's great it keeps everything strong
and you're not really
you know you're not pushing once i get
weights yeah i'd like to look at that
i'm not going to do it but once i get to
a certain level
of strength um but the thing is you can
do it it's not going to hurt you because
you you're not you're just doing it
lightly like this you've got a lawsuit
coming your way buddy
look this is i just thought of something
i just forgot something that i learned
about myself with that [ __ ] that'll come
to me
as far as like with rehabilitation yeah
but it also came into my personality
just something that i i kind of
oh this is what i learned about myself
and why i didn't miss stand up because
it was freaking me out
is because what i experienced as a kid
straight across the board uh made me go
to this mental place
of like i don't care [ __ ] it i don't
care i don't need it i don't give a [ __ ]
and that caused
that cause that's what caused everything
to get walled off
and that actually feeds into rehabbing
injuries because it was a big moment for
me
where i got this [ __ ] console thing
that i'm trying to put in my podcast
studio and they're supposed to deliver
it and bring it in there right
so the day they were gonna deliver it my
wife went into labor
so i went to the hospital and then they
showed up and i didn't want them going
out my garage i got all my memorabilia
and [ __ ] i just didn't want people in
there unless i was there so i said i
just had them drop it off
i thought it was going to be a box and
it was already assembled and it was
[ __ ]
big right and it was also the weight
load of it i was just i was like ah [ __ ]
if i keep my arms in like this it's
mostly biceps and i was gonna do this
and i was gonna do this stupid
german irish [ __ ] it and what it was
gonna do
was gonna set me back once again like i
had a big setback in february
i had an acting gig and they said hey it
was just a stupid little
action thing it's a wall put your hands
on it hop over can you do that i'm like
yeah my shoulder feels pretty good and
the second i went like that i felt like
lightning go down my shoulder and i was
like ah
[ __ ] right back to the [ __ ] tuna
canning and all that [ __ ] so
i actually
had a friend come over we were gonna do
it i said you know what dude
i i i owe you a [ __ ] dinner or
something
i'm not doing this and i called up this
guy that i knew was a construction
company
you got a couple of strong young guys
that can just move this thing in there
and i just had them do it and and like
and that's like something that i'm
pushing through where
um it helps me as a comic it also helps
me deal with highly
emotional [ __ ] because i can just shut
[ __ ] off and just
do what i have to do which works like
back in the day when you're gonna do
letterman which was [ __ ] terrifying
it's freezing cold
and you just have to be like [ __ ] this
just it's just [ __ ] people
this is just a different shiny floor
that's freaking me out and there's an
icon sitting at that desk
i i had the tools to shut that off which
is great for that moment
but it's terrible for the rest of your
[ __ ] life like this [ __ ] that's
like i just realized there's just [ __ ]
in me that i needed
that i i have not dealt with death of
friends
all of that [ __ ] is just sitting in here
and i think that's also
like when people then go like
oh hey can you do this oh what the [ __ ]
like it's not all just that
i'm not gonna get what i want a lot of
that is like you got all of this [ __ ]
that you're sitting on so you're sitting
on all that and you haven't addressed it
so then it just it
the only way for the steam to come out
is like
for you to snap or whatever so which is
really
not fair to the people around you
to be honest with you so i don't know
have you gone to therapy
yeah yeah yeah what about meditating
you ever meditate yeah but i find the
guy's voice is [ __ ] annoying you
don't have to
listen
[Laughter]
every time i'm getting there he starts
[ __ ] talking again and then he's
using this really soothing caring voice
that makes me face all of that [ __ ] that
i didn't get growing up which makes me
angry at this person
that's trying to help me wow yeah
quarantine is not a bad thing if
for what it's worth you're always fun to
hang around with i always enjoy your
company
i don't have any issues with any of your
crazy because i have a crushing need to
be liked
[Laughter]
so i tone down my cuntiness when i'm
around you
listen my wife knows me hang out with
her one time she'll tell you some
[ __ ] stories
i'm sure yeah
well the you that i get i like
if that helps you yeah you know the deal
you don't know anybody till you live
with them
all right you know
i will i will not accept your
compliments that's another part of my
personality
who's the guy that's running the
meditation app that's annoying you
do you know whose app you're using i
don't want to put the guy on blast but
yeah i do
okay let me know and he's great he's
great
what he's doing he's trying to help
people i understand yeah
you should do it without an app dude i i
have a story i can't say
i can't say what i said nowadays i can't
say what i said but i remember
i was playing pickup hockey and i suck
right but i'm having a good time out
there i'm just you know
i'm out there trying to get a sweat
going right and you know i'm having my
head down and we're playing no contact
and because i had it was really my fault
i had my head down on this guy [ __ ]
knock me down on the other team and he
goes are you all right
yeah what i said to that guy i still
[ __ ] regret
[Laughter]
i was so mad at him that he was caring
in that moment
like and that's one of those things it
was like what is wrong with me
wow so you you're really trying to come
to grips with all this [ __ ] right now
yeah because i don't want to pass this
[ __ ] on to my kids
that's what happens and it's just like
yeah when people are like uh
if people say my kids are not like me
like i'm like good
that's weird but i i do think that a lot
if they're like oh yeah he's
you know she's like you know happy go
like great
like i forget what somebody said one
time
about my daughter because she's like
jesus angel right and
they made some sort of you know comic
made the comment you know thinking it
was gonna hurt me and i was like yeah
dude that's [ __ ] music to my ears i
don't
i don't want to be like me but don't
do you think they were trying to hurt
you when they said it no it was one of
those comic things where they don't have
kids so and it was a guy's and they
don't know what to say
so then they got to like make a [ __ ]
joke
like i had a body of mind a comedian on
my birthday he goes hey
happy destroying your mother's uterus
day
and i just remember laughing going like
oh there's a guy has to do a little more
work than i have to
or i can say i can say i know but i mean
i know what it is it was a boston comic
and he couldn't just say
happy birthday because that would be gay
right so he has to go
to so over correct that has to go to
that level
it's so [ __ ] stupid it's probably why
guys die before women
you hang on to [ __ ] and there's all that
stuff you know
can't say enjoy sunset joe you can't do
that
why can't you shut up but i know why
i know you do i know but the thing about
you is you can also beat the [ __ ] out of
most people in a [ __ ] room
so you got that so people can be like oh
wow you know they actually want to hear
that from you
when they see you spinning heel kick
they want to know that you enjoy a
sunset because like i don't want
if this guy's as angry as i am and can
do all of that [ __ ]
what are my odds of getting out of here
so you want to see that out of a guy
like
you the guy like you you don't want to
see it
don't want to see you and join us on set
joe i don't read i don't
know i don't know what it is i am
i am too in here to understand me
this is interesting i have a very s i
have a very
weird thing i have an alley of my
personality that works that i somehow
turned into a living
yeah but the rest of it looks like fred
samford's yard
[Laughter]
old radiators and bed frames and [ __ ]
it's a [ __ ] mess
it's interesting because i've never seen
you this introspective where you're
really trying to work it out
you're really thinking about it more
than i've ever seen you think about it
before
you've always joked around about it you
know
and all the years i've known you it's
always been a part of the things you
talk about
but it seems uh much more
at the forefront of your consciousness
right now like something you really need
to work on you really realize like this
is
i gotta fix this yeah i think it started
last year doing the movie
oh he brings back the movie um
it was there was a bunch of [ __ ] that i
had to play
that i never had to play before you want
me to be a loud [ __ ] [ __ ]
i can do that but then all of a sudden
like
uh i had a lot of anxiety about a lot of
the stuff like my character had two kids
and like the first time i meet the kids
it's classic
acting where it's just like you just
show up
i remember i took this acting class this
guy brendan hughes he was great he was
saying like he was talking about what
it's like to go on a movie set it's just
like how you have to have access to all
these emotions because you're showing
up and it's just like okay uh you're
this guy
and this is your dad and your mother
just died and action
and it's just like what because that's
the way it goes it just goes real quick
so yeah
so i have to play like this uh so i got
two kids here
so the first day i met them we had to do
the family photo
they wanted to have one of those things
in the background for a scene so you
have to and i'm sitting there going like
ah [ __ ] you know i gotta i gotta act
like
i love these kids the way i love my kids
like and that's was really confronting
for me as far as how i'm wired well [ __ ]
you i don't need anybody so
uh i i had like a [ __ ] panic attack
before
like really even that thing like just
being like
just that comic thing where uh you're
just like dude i just i stand on stage
i do [ __ ] jokes for a [ __ ] hour you
give the check and then i [ __ ] leave
i smoke cigars [ __ ] leave me alone
right and this thing here it's like
no you you're now on a schedule somebody
tells you where you have to be so like
you know i was like a cat on a leash all
of a sudden like yeah i have to be
all these places so i was freaking out
about that and then the
i had to do the picture with the kids so
what i did was
i just i got myself into a really silly
mood
and i was deliberately i was joking with
all the other actors i was making fun of
myself
i was joking with anybody that had
anything to do with the movie i got this
really silly stupid move and i just
to get myself in that headspace and then
i met them i started joking around
about what i looked like and this is
what your dad looked like and then they
started laughing
so when they took the picture we were
actually laughing about a joke i was
making about
myself and then i looked at the pictures
and they looked
they looked real they look like i love
these kids so
i got over that hurdle so like
throughout the shoot
you know obviously the [ __ ] yelling at
pete it's like i can [ __ ] do that all
day
but all that other stuff and it's like
okay and you know jeb would be like okay
and then you meet margie
and you're smitten and it's like smitten
i
i you know i've never had i've been
smitten
in life but i've never you know as a
comedian i don't think you ever really
go on stage
you know if you were to do something
where you were smitten you're me you're
making fun of that emotion and the
stupid things that you do it's like no
we need you to play this
real like you really have just and i'm
like oh so
i'm like into her he goes no i'm your
love struck like a lightning bolt and
i'm just like
that's like oh geez like i don't know
how to [ __ ] do this and you know
[ __ ] in there
oh my god i mean i had him in my head
this person's won an oscar they're gonna
think i suck you know just going through
all of that [ __ ] so it took me probably
uh two weeks on the film
i was two weeks in they had shot enough
of my [ __ ] where i was like all right
they're not gonna fire me
i can kind of relax a little bit and
then after that i had i had a
i did i had a great time i had a [ __ ]
great time
best time i've had on uh any acting gigs
and i've had a lot of fun throughout the
years so
i think that's what sort of started it
and i was kind of like
you know trying to communicate it to my
wife
and she doesn't know what i'm talking
about she's like you're doing a movie
this is [ __ ] great and she has
access you know opposites attract so she
has access to all of that [ __ ]
she's actually uh you know a [ __ ] way
better actor than i am and stuff so i i
she helps me out a lot so after those
two weeks i was able to chill and then i
had a great time
and i got over a bunch of hurdles and i
was kind of like oh this is like growing
as a comic
where it's like okay i i know how to do
this as a comic
what if i try to act something out oh
that's not my safe space
now i start feeling like an open micro
again and they're not going to like me
i'm like stop getting spots at the store
go home live home with my parents i
start doing that [ __ ] yeah
the whole show going on up here joe did
you watch it after it was done
yeah i i watched the initial cut of it
and then i saw the final version of it
and everything
did you enjoy it yeah it's one of those
things you're just too
you you know everything that was there
and wasn't there
and like uh and like especially with
jokes like there was there was some
you know there's always going to be
stuff that you oh god i wish why did
they cut there i wish they put this
in but like as far as like the movie
itself i loved it how it worked
and the way they put it together and
there's the opening scene
that's in the movie initially was in the
middle of the movie and somebody judd i
don't know who
came up with the brilliant idea to put
that scene first and it totally changed
the tone
of the movie and it and that's when it
like
took off because i saw a real raw cut
and it was like this is a bunch of funny
[ __ ]
and like everybody i've ever talked to
edits a movie like when they watch their
first cut in the movie they're like oh
my god i'm never gonna
i'm never gonna work in this business
again i just wasted my [ __ ]
you know i was actually uh talking to
one of the actors who had
directed one of my favorite movies uh uh
trees lounge
steve buscemi made that movie and he
told us this [ __ ] hilarious story
about
the you know when he the first cut that
he watched of it like
he just like went home like a zombie you
know like going oh my god like how am i
gonna make and it's such a great movie
by the time he was done editing it but
his first
like look at it so that helped me out
a guy as good as him having that type of
thought i was just like oh geez i think
that [ __ ] all the time
you know this guy's an icon if he thinks
that then this is normal
so like all right i guess i'm kind of
normal to think this [ __ ] so yeah so i
think that started it and then i just
kind of would have just been happy to
get through the movie
and then that would have been it and
then i had to be quarantined
oh we all got come on i'm like myself
typical self-involved me
everybody's quarantined and then that
just became me sitting around and i was
like i'm not watching tv because this is
just gonna
[ __ ] make me feel like claustrophobic
watching all this news and [ __ ] trying
to be informed so i kind of went away
from that
and then i was just in the house with me
just sitting there and everybody was
asleep and
it was [ __ ] just thinking thinking
but not in a bad way i don't think i
don't know
well it doesn't seem like it's a bad way
it seems like you've isolated some of
the things that you
you have a problem with that you need to
work out yeah i mean that's uh
that's one great leap on the way to
figuring it out is knowing what you're
trying to work on
some people go to their whole life not
understanding what the [ __ ] is wrong
with you i'm jealous of those people
i grew up a lot of those people those
people watch tv all the time
no they just they are who they are
and they just [ __ ] do that there is
something i i you know that i have
actually
it's so [ __ ] up there's people like
when i look at people
that just do whatever the [ __ ] they want
to do
you know like who doesn't want to just
[ __ ] eat a large cheese pizza
and then finish it off with the pineapp
ice cream like
those people that do that i know they
pay for it but there is something to be
i'm reading this book right now on uh
bobby lane who's a quarterback
for the uh detroit lions and there's all
these legends
like his story is so legendary you don't
even know where the the the the legend
isn't where the truth is but like
this guy art donovan used to tell a
story about you know he was on the other
team and
he sacked him and you know he's getting
up and
bobby breathed on him goes jesus christ
man where the [ __ ] did you go last night
and bobby allegedly said last night he
goes i had a couple of pops at halftime
you know these guys were [ __ ]
lunatics and he lived this life where he
had this wide array of friends
uh really progressive where he he
like you know through playing sports he
had
uh african-american friends and if they
were to go into some place and they said
your friend can't come in he goes no
we're not [ __ ] going in i mean this
guy
was doing this in the 50s and 60s right
and um
he was always like that and but he died
at like 58 or 59
and it was hard for all of his friends
to see him you know not being like the
legend but there's a great part in the
book
where he's talking about his life and um
like knowing that you know he probably
should have gone easier but like this
big smile came on his face that he kind
of did it the way he wanted to
because believe me dude i would love to
go home and kill a bottle of bourbon
right now i would love to
smoke another [ __ ] five of these
[ __ ] things but uh i got too many
people depending on me
but um there is something to be said
about living you know those people they
just
like i like booze i like it i like
getting drunk and just
if i want to do it every night i'm
[ __ ] going to do it i live at home i
want to get a pizza i'm going to have a
[ __ ] pizza
you do pay for it but there is i i made
me think of like
well what's from motorhead well what's
yeah what's that life like
yeah as opposed to being like well you
know i got to make sure i eat my
brussels sprouts and i flake
and you kind of inch your way to death
as opposed to just being like [ __ ] it
pizza tastes good
i want a pizza [ __ ] it i'm having one
let's try every bourbon that i like i
love that in the lemmy dock
when he just had all those suburban the
greatest thing the lemmy thing was when
those guys were saying
let me go hey you want you want some
jack daniels they go yeah and he takes a
bottle down
and then hands both of them their own
bottle and they were like what the [ __ ]
and he starts just
drinking out of this like he's having a
coke
dean delray said something [ __ ]
hilarious about when he watches the
lemmy duck
he goes dude if i saw that thing when i
was in my 20s
and i knew lemmy was gonna live to be
70. he goes i never would have stopped
[Laughter]
his last days were rough though i
remember i think everybody's last days
are rough unless you drop
dead but his last days on performing i
mean he he basically performed
until the wheels fell off there's a
video of him
like one of the last shows that he did
where he had to walk off stage in the
middle of his performance
he was such a [ __ ] badass even like
just the way he had the microphone the
way he would sing well he just came in
the [ __ ] bass was all low
yeah can't teach that man that guy was
[ __ ] in his dna
well he lived it that's for sure and he
is a legend
and there's something to be said for
that there's
it's all what you put your energy to
yeah it's kind of how
you like you notice it's the balls to
live that life yeah indulgent
and wild yeah where like there's there's
all this heroicism to sobriety
but which there is yeah being sober and
just taking life in the face every day
is is [ __ ] hard and i think
uh to see somebody but that has the
balls
even with all the surgeon general [ __ ]
as i'm sitting here smoking a [ __ ]
cigar looking for a toothpick if you
have one
um no no toothpick who's got
the piece of stick right there sticking
in here
this is why i had to stop cigars because
i'll smoke it right down on my [ __ ]
fingers
here whittle that thing down jesus
christ joe
give me that stick oh is that the way
you're supposed to hand somebody a knife
well i was gonna oh you were gonna do it
yeah
i don't need you joe i don't need
anybody good luck
i [ __ ] need to eat a roach clip you
want another cigar so you don't have to
do that
i mean we have now this is the best part
that's the best part of cigar yeah it's
the most full you get the smoke goes
right to you
yeah okay
i feel like i'm in therapy i feel like
i'm a therapist right now listen
don't switch to kid glove tone with me
all right i'm just [ __ ] around here
i'm sorry bill
see that just uh just trying to assess
the situation
how are you is that what your training
has taught you
[Laughter]
you talked all these whack jobs on your
[ __ ] podcast
the lemmy thing is you know that's one
of the things that people love about
them right
because everybody knows you're supposed
to eat well everybody knows you're not
supposed to
get [ __ ] up every night everybody
knows you're supposed to be responsible
and mature and and smart
but what he did was just he didn't work
no no it's gonna be slippery look at him
there he was just wild
wild to the end yeah and i think you
need you need people like that you do
you do because you can get a lot out of
the way that they live where every once
in a while you'll be like you know what
[ __ ] this let's go let's be lemmy today
yeah you get you get great art out of
those people too
the those wild people the buckowskis and
the
sam kinnisons and the lemmies and the
people that just
[ __ ] go hard there's something to
that yeah there's something to that too
yeah there's also something to people
that are stoic
you know what's interesting to me is the
just
the range of people i can get i can get
things out of people that just
drink water and meditate and i'm
fascinated by them
i'm fascinated by people like i was
watching some uh
do you know russell simmons he lives in
like where does he live in like
bali or indonesia or something like that
he was doing a
an instagram live and he's doing it
cross-legged with like uh some crazy
yoga shawl over his knees and [ __ ] and
like it looked like an ashram
and he's like he's he's basically
talking like a yogi
in an australia this guy was the head of
def jam
yeah and he got like really really into
yoga
and now he lives in some country
somewhere and just
[ __ ] does yoga he's doing instagram
live talking to people
like like uh like a guru
yeah i ain't gonna go that hard
i'm not either i'll do uh i'll do a yo i
mean i i kind of do my own version
of yoga just [ __ ] that i've learned do
you do a little yoga
i stretch all the time yeah i have to
because i
i uh you know you just get to a certain
age
if you don't i mean you know yeah i love
stretching yeah you kind of got to do
all of that [ __ ] so
anyway enough of that you ever take a
yoga class
yeah like hot yoga you ever do that i i
almost i just felt like i couldn't
breathe
yeah and i remember too also like my
back was [ __ ] up
that's why i went to the class and the
put like
the position she started out with the
twisting was happening too quickly
so i kind of just went down the mat and
i was doing all the thing and the
teacher got like all freaked out by it
really she's like come on you know try
to stay with the class you can't be like
busting out all these different asanas
and i just started [ __ ] laughing
where i was just thinking like
this is all supposed to be about
listening to your body and you're
literally
you're like the oil man in here trying
to control this is your own little
[ __ ] economy
and just the fact that i [ __ ] you're
walking around like you got it all
figured out
you got 99 of people here all doing what
the [ __ ] you say and one guy
goes down to his mat because his back is
[ __ ] up and you
process it like i'm [ __ ] with your
authority in a yoga class
[Music]
so with my broad brush
i said [ __ ] hot yoga
that's hilarious yeah well yoga teachers
like everything else
you know some of them you're going to
enjoy some of them are going to be
really good at it and some of them are
going to annoy the [ __ ] out of you what
annoys the [ __ ] out of me is when they
start giving you motivational advice
and telling you how to live your life
you've got to learn to let go of things
like for me and then tell some personal
story
and so yeah what i got out of that like
jesus christ can we [ __ ] move on here
i didn't come here to hear your first
grade i used to go to this country
psychology it was a great class
it was a great class but the dude he had
it was [ __ ] awesome i like i was
after a while ago i was just
psychologically breaking this guy down
and something happened to him at a
gold's gym
i don't know what happened to him and
like he just was forever
making fun of muscle heads and i was
thinking you know because i've
had the hybrid thing going on like i you
know back before i [ __ ] up my shoulder
i loved lifting weights i loved going to
the gym and all that [ __ ]
and i liked the energy in a gym
you know i i i liked it and um
the old school ones right when the guys
used to walk around with the towels
tucked into their [ __ ]
you know that [ __ ] and he was forever
[ __ ] on it and then another thing
that he would do
would he would uh also somehow
steer it toward like a subtle comment
about lovemaking
and the way to and he was putting out
like
his vibe that he was good in bed at the
same time
[Music]
oh that's a yoga guy move oh
you know and he had the little ponytail
and [ __ ] it was [ __ ] no
it was like a will ferrell character it
was [ __ ] funny it was like
this is like it was like a real life
like
will ferrell like uh
like just really just like i know
everything kind of vibe it was he wasn't
as bad as that but it was just
that they did it yeah it was funny
though and i used to sit there
uh yeah this was like this dude in new
york i remember it was [ __ ] hilarious
and it was hilarious
was i was bad at yoga if there's that
you're not supposed to even say that if
you're doing it man you just you know
wherever your body's at is where you're
supposed to be right
and i just remember when he would walk
around the class and he would adjust
people
he'd always skip me and then adjust some
hot chick who is way more flexible than
me
and it's just like really i'm doing it
right as i'm sitting over here for some
reason i never needed an adjustment
and it was this was like the 90s so you
could get away with this [ __ ] there was
a lot of adjusting
like this almost cupping a titty and
[ __ ] like yeah
[ __ ] on their hips and stuff yeah hey
god bless him
it's like a pied piper he got all these
hot chicks in there and you get them all
stretched out before he banged him and
it worked
so i couldn't hate on him for that but
it was
i i to get through the class because
i've such [ __ ] a d
d i was just there was like a comedy
show going on within it like you know
like a house and then like a couple
buddies i thought you gotta go
you know we'll do look at you know like
a bet when he's gonna [ __ ] how many
times
he's gonna [ __ ] on the gym um what does
he say
um what would he say he would talk about
he would talk about the muscle heads
coming in there
and they had no flexibility and you know
and how uh everything was all like over
developed
but you know he we'd always been doing
some [ __ ] up uh
pose or something and he goes this works
on your psoas
like what machine in the gym
you know is there a psoas machine you
know like i can't i was like [ __ ] it
was a long time ago
and um at first it pissed me off it's
just like well i like [ __ ] doing
curls what's wrong
and then it just became funny to me
there's a specific type of guy that's
like that
i went to a yoga guy once used to
singing classes
he wound up like does he want to bang in
this lady that was there oh that was a
lot back in the day he can't do it now
yeah
there was a lot of banging back then
this was like uh
i guess it was late 90s early 2000s
maybe
and he would sing in class and it was so
cheap
it was so disingenuous oh yeah
like you would do these like yoga songs
i'm like you are so gross
there was but there was some really uh
good ones that i found i found out you
know some yeah there's some really good
ones
this is really this guy i go to i mean
you hear him talk you think he's going
to be annoying he's got pierced nipples
the whole deal
but he's really sincere he's really into
it
he's so gay he's so gay it's like oozing
when he talks
but you know he's just so that means the
way it's
so gay like the way he talks we're here
we're here you're supposed to be here
let it go and but he that's who he is
like he's comfortable
he's well that's the last class well
that's the thing is if
as if it's genuine yeah yeah yeah then
it becomes this great thing
yeah um that's who he is he's uh
yeah it's uh it's like whoever the [ __ ]
you are
if that's who you are like i like it i
don't i don't
want you to try to sell me on who you
are
like the guy with the love making that
goes the last two hours of this podcast
the selling you on who they are is where
it gets really gross pretending to be
something they're not
not be i mean i like flaws it's good
we all have them you know so
my favorite people are all flawed i
don't mind
and it's not even that guy was flawed he
was just uh
he was just like normally you would
think if a guy was talking like that
teaching a yoga class like this is not
gonna be fun
but it was great yeah there's a lot of
people that are really good at it man
it's just finding them you know so i
like the place that i go to i just
look at the schedule i'm like oh that's
a good one i'll take her class i like
him
he's fun yeah and there's this one dude
he has
weird tattoos like real strange like
it always has to be clean too because
there's so much sweating going on
i hate when you go like those hot yoga
classes there's just no way to get this
the floors were sweating
like there's just no way to he's got to
accept it it's so good for your body
so good for your stretching too because
you can get into positions when you're
doing hot yoga
that you're not going to get into and
it's like really stretching that tissue
out and extending your range of motion
i love it i i'm a [ __ ] evangelist for
it though i tell so many people to do it
a lot of people have listened but more
people just get annoyed well i love that
when you guys do the sober october
you know when i watch segura and [ __ ]
uh uh
chrysler dry out and like three weeks in
they start looking like movie stars and
[ __ ]
that's always well when we did the
fitness one we did one sober october
fitness challenge we all wore these uh
uh these straps and we we had to like
compete to see who can get the the most
fitness points and stuff like that ari
got a [ __ ] six-pack
like ari got shredded like he doesn't
even work out he like
before that he was never working out and
over the course of the month by the end
of the month he had a legit
six-pack and he looked great he was he's
always pretty wiry though yeah
thin yeah he got fat at one point in
time because he was eating
nothing but candy he was literally
eating candy all day long he was always
he was like a bag of gummy bears with
him and [ __ ] like that
but then i got to play i don't know if i
still have the message when we're done
with this i got to play the message
him congratulating me having a kid it's
so already it's so [ __ ] funny
[Laughter]
but yeah he uh he dried out with that
and then uh
didn't he never gained it back but he
never never had that six-pack again he
was shredded
because he was super competitive he was
really trying to win it was really
interesting it was interesting to watch
and i liked how bert would do it too
where bert would have like
i don't he would always have like a
crazy build-up
that was totally against what he told me
this
story about him running the [ __ ]
uh la marathon and like drinking the
night before it's just like dude you
could have [ __ ]
died and probably never really trained
for it but he but he just but he
he he's mentally strong he just got
himself from this mindset of put one
foot in front of the other and i am not
stopping
until i get to the finish line
26 miles [ __ ] the [ __ ] hell of a hall
for a fat guy
he did it yeah he won't catch me doing
that no
no marathon running no did you run at
all um
no i was not i used to uh ride a bike
i did that for a while where i and uh i
got
so into it and one time i i actually was
drinking in the afternoon and i still
had to go on a bike ride i got on a bike
[ __ ] face it was sweating
this is the 80s too no helmet no nothing
and just [ __ ] rode like like 12 miles
and i never had heard the expression i
never felt hitting a wall
like whatever the electrolytes were
there was just nothing left
and i was like six miles in this east
coast there's all kinds of hills and
[ __ ] from my house and i was like
i i don't think i i don't what am i
gonna and there was no cell phones like
what am i gonna do
so i just kept riding and then it was
like this
five minute like i'm gonna die i'm not
gonna get through this and then i
just got to the other side where the i
think my body was just like
all right there must be something like
death must be chasing us so we need to
go into something else here
and i push through into that that's what
they say happens when you do those ultra
marathons those people they get to a
point where they think there's no way
they can keep going
they're doing 100 miles and they're 38
miles in
and they're ready to quit but they just
managed to just keep left
right left right left right and
eventually you get into a zone and you
cross the finish line 20 hours later hey
god bless them now that's
that i would just say well that you have
all the people handing you cups of [ __ ]
and you can just
tap there's a lot of things you have to
do in those 24-hour races you have to
eat
like you run dry it's not like a regular
marathon
yeah no i'm i'm not yeah those are
triathlons
billboard has been a great therapy
session thank you uh
um season four coming out tomorrow
you have time to do that how the [ __ ] do
you have time to do efforts for family
as well as stand up as well as all the
other [ __ ] you do play the drums
delegation yeah you you you surround
yourself with super talented people
you do your job they do their job and
you're able to
uh be able to do that able to do it but
i
i i i needed this break though i'm not
gonna lie to you i needed it too
i didn't think i needed it i thought it
was fine but now i am like
[ __ ] chomping at the bit to get back
on stage i can't wait and i
yeah i miss hearing people laughing and
hanging with comics and hearing the
crazy [ __ ] they say
next time i see you i hope it's at the
store yes or the troubadour the
troubadour either one either or i'm in
bill ladies and gentlemen thank you so
much bye brother all right
all right is that good